CALLING- OF THIS HEARING OF THE
ASSEMBLY EDUCATION COMMITTEE TO
ORDER. WELL THE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM CHELSEA
KELLY'S ARE ACTING SECRETARY
TODAY. SO WE PATIENT WHETHER
SHE'S DONE THIS MANY TIMES OUR
CONSULTANTS OF THANK YOU
CHELSEA. ALL HERE FINALLY THERE
SENATE. SALLY WE HEAR PARTY
WORKS A LOT. YEAH OKAY QUORUM
HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED I'D LIKE
TO WELCOME- COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO
TODAY'S HEARING- BEFORE WE
BEGIN WITH OUR AGENDA I'D LIKE
TO RECOGNIZE THAT WE HAVE THREE
NEW MEMBERS SERVING ON THE
COMMITTEE- WE HAVE A MINUTE-
ALEX LEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALEX
LEE AND- ASSEMBLY MEMBER SHARON
QUIRK SILVA. AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BENNETT IS JUST WALKED
IN THE DOOR- SO WITH THAT- WHAT
IF WHAT IF I ANY OF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO JUST MAKE A QUICK
COMMENT. WE WELCOME YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE. AND- THIS CONGRESS
CORDIAL. I AM VERY EXCITED TO
BE. THIRTY YEARS CLASSROOM
TEACHER AND- LOOK FORWARD TO
THE- BILLS INTRODUCED MANY.
GREAT GREAT YOU MISS
QUICKSILVER MR LEE- THE SAME
AIRPLANE HONORED ON EDUCATION
AT SELLING THAT ONE THROUGH
THAT YOU CAN SYSTEM A TWENTY
FOUR CENTURY I- PROBABLY
WORKING ON IT FOR THE RECORD.
WE GET THE- GREAT MISTER ABOUT.
I APPRECIATE THE SOMETHING OF
WHAT YOU WERE THAT TWENTIETH
CENTURY. I HOPE ALL BALLOTS THE
WE IT WAS IN FACT WILL. WE
HAVE- WE HAVE A MOTION TO ADOPT
THE COMMITTEE RULES. AND THE-
REMOVED AND SECONDED- PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. HI RIGHT NOT A.
THANKS BYE. BALANCE HI WE HI
MCCARTY FOR CALLING OUT OF.
OKAY I'M SORRY MOTION PASSES
MOTION PASSES SO THE BILL THE
COMMITTEE- RULES HAVE BEEN
ADOPTED. WE HAVE NINETEEN BILLS
ON FILE TODAY AND EIGHT ARE ON
CONSENT ONE MEASURE HAS BEEN
PULLED FROM THE AGENDA THAT IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN AB. ONE OH
ONE THE MEASURES ON CONSENT ARE
AS FOLLOWS AB ONE TWENTY SIX
WITH AMENDMENTS AB TWO EIGHTY
FIVE EIGHTY THREE OH SIX WITH
AMENDMENTS A. B. THREE TWENTY
AB FOUR THIRTY SEVEN AB FIVE
ONE SIX AB EIGHT FIVE SIX WITH
AMENDMENTS. AB TEN THIRTY NINE-
MANY BILLS THIS YEAR- A LOT OF
BILL A LOT OF IDEAS WILL COME
FOR THE EDUCATION COMMITTEE I
JUST REMIND MEMBERS CERTAINLY
INSIDE THE COMMITTEE AND
OUTSIDE THE COMMITTEE THAT MANY
SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA AREN'T
EVEN OPEN. SO ALL THE GRAND
IDEAS THAT PEOPLE HAVE ABOUT
WHAT'S TEACHER SHOULD DO IN THE
CLASS OR WHAT SCHOOLS SHOULD BE
DOING- MIGHT NEED TO TAKE A
PAUSE BECAUSE I THINK OUR
BIGGEST PRIORITY WE WOULD AGREE
IN THIS CLASSROOM IS NUMBER ONE
GETTING OUR SCHOOLS RE OPEN AND
NUMBER TWO ADDRESSING LEARNING
LOSS I THINK I THINK MOST MANY
MEMBERS WOULD AGREE WITH ME ON
THAT- SO THAT SHOULD BE THE
PRIORITY. SO THOSE GREAT IDEAS
THIS YEAR PROBABLY TO BE SCALED
BACK I KNOW WE HAD ABOUT A
HUNDRED TWENTY ISSUE GREAT
IDEAS. SOME OF THOSE IN SPOT
BILL FORM EVEN STILL TODAY. AND
WE CERTAINLY ARE NOT GOING TO
HEAR PROBABLY EVEN HALF OF
THOSE. IF EVEN THAT. WITH THAT-
PLEASE KNOW THAT WE WILL BE
HEARING THE BILL'S IN FILE
ORDER WITH COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PRESENTING LAST COMMITTEE
MEMBERS PRESENTING LAST. IN
ORDER TO MOVE THROUGH OUR
AGENDA EFFICIENTLY WE WILL TRY
TO KEEP THE HEARING ON EACH
BILL TO NO MORE THAN TWENTY
MINUTES. SO EACH BILL. NO MORE
THAN TWENTY MINUTES- AND- IT IN
ANTICIPATION- OF THE FACT WE'RE
GOING TO MORE BILLS THE NEXT
HEARING THAT'S REALLY. GOING TO
BE SOMETHING RUN HAVE TO STICK
TO BECAUSE WE HAVE A LIMITED
TIME WHEN I WENT OUT WE HAVE A
DROP. WE HAVE AS THE- HARD STOP
TIME BECAUSE AND OTHER
COMMITTEE HAS TO COME IN THERE
TO CLEAN THE ROOM. THAT IS
TURNED OVER TO ANOTHER
COMMITTEE. SO THIS ISN'T
SOMETHING LIKE. IN YEARS PAST
JUST FOR THE NEWARK MEMBERS AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO THIS IS
SOMETHING WE CAN JUST. LET GO
AND- AND WELL WE CAN BE HERE
TILL TEN O'CLOCK AT NIGHT WE
HAVE A HARD STOP. AND WE NEED
TO GET OUT OF THIS ROOM FOR THE
NEXT COMMITTEE AND THE
CLEANING. SO WE WILL INVITE
OPPOSITION AFTER MEMBER
QUESTIONS AND WE'LL HEAR UP TO
TEN MINUTES. OF PHONE TESTIMONY
IT'S TEN MINUTES OF PHONE JUST
MONEY. UP TO. AS WELL AS ANY
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN. THE HEARING ROOM.
BEFORE WE BEGIN I A STATEMENT
TO READ. TO READ REGARDING OUR
PROCESS TODAY. WE CONTINUE TO
PRACTICE PHYSICAL DISTANCING
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM SO
WE'RE ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A
LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE. WATCH
AND PARTICIPATE INSIDE THIS
HEARING ROOM. WE ARE ALSO
REQUIRING THAT MASS BE WORN AND
PHYSICAL DISTANCING BE
MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC. TESTIFYING WEATHER
HERE IN THE ROOM OR AT. OTHER
VIDEO CONFERENCING SITE. IF YOU
DO NOT HAVE A MASK WE CAN
PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU WE HAVE
SEVERAL OPTIONS FOR WITNESS
TESTIMONY TODAY. IF ANY MEMBER
OF THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY ON A BILL. YOU
MAY APPROACH THE MICROPHONE
WHEN WE INVITE. COMMENT FROM
PEOPLE IN THE ROOM. WE ALSO
HAVE TWO PRIMARY WITNESS. IS
USING ONE OF OUR WITNESS VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOM WE WILL ALSO
BE USING A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE FOR TESTIMONY. THE CALL
IN NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN. YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY EDUCATION COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV
SCREEN. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO AS THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOU'RE
TESTIFYING ON IS BEGINNING.
THEIR PRESENTATION CALLING AS
THEY BEGIN THEIR PRESENTATION
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE THIS INCLUDES. MUTING
YOUR LIVESTREAM BROADCAST AND
YOUR SMART DEVICES IF YOU HAVE
ANY PROBLEMS WITH A MODERATE
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX.
THREE ONE NINE. TWO ZERO EIGHT
SEVEN. WE'RE ALSO ACCEPTING
WRITTEN TESTIMONY FROM THE
POSITION LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE WHICH
BECOMES PART OF THE OFFICIAL
RECORD OF THE BILL THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE AS WE
IMPLEMENT THESE PRACTICES TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. AKORN HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED WITH THAT LET'S
MOVE ON TO OUR FIRST ORDER OF
BUSINESS WHICH WE'VE ALREADY
CONDUCTED WHICH IS ADOPTING THE
COMMITTEE RULES- AND WE'LL NOW
MOVE YOUR FIRST AUTHOR THAT'S
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN. WHO HAS
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO EIGHTY
FIVE SIX THREE AND AGAIN AS YOU
WISH TO- SHARED OPINION ON THIS
BILL AND IN YOUR OPINION WOULD
ONLY BE A OTHER THAN A WITNESS
WHO ALREADY KNOW WHO THEY ARE.
WHEN YOU CALL AND YOU WOULD
STATE YOUR NAME AFFILIATION IF
YOU'RE WITH A GROUP AND YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY%
NOTHING MORE YOU'LL BE CUT OFF.
AND I HAD TO THE MODERATOR IF
ANYONE GOES ON A DIATRIBE THAT
SHOULD NOT PLEASE CUT THEM OFF
IMMEDIATELY WE MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT CALLER. IF SOMEONE IS NOT
THERE THEY CANNOT GET ON-
PLEASE MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
CALLER SO THEY CAN BE AS
EFFICIENT. WITH OUR TIME AND
THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN A
READY TO SPEAK ON A BILL OR
SHARE AN OPINION MAY DO SO WITH
THAT WE'RE GOING TO MISTER
BERMAN- AND HE IS AB FIVE SIX
THREE PLEASE PROCEED IN READING.
THAT IS. HAS THE HELLO THERE
YEP THAT WORKING. IS JOHN. OKAY
MISTER BURN YOUR LIVE GREAT
THANK YOU FOR THE WARNING
GIORDANO IN LET ME START BY
THINKING YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP AND PARTNERSHIP
ON THIS CRITICAL ISSUE I'LL
ALSO BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES TECHNICAL AMENDMENT
AND I'M GRATEFUL TO HAVE THE
CHAIR ADDED ON AS A JOINT
AUTHORS OF THIS BILL SCHOOL
BASED HEALTH SERVICES PLAY A
KEY ROLE IN ENSURING THAT
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS ARE HEALTHY
AND READY TO LEARN. K. THROUGH
TWELVE SCHOOLS ARE ELIGIBLE TO
RECEIVE FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENT
FOR HEALTH SERVICES PROVIDED AT
SCHOOL SITES THROUGH A PROGRAM
CALLED THE LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCY MEDIC CAL BILLING OPTION
PROGRAM HOWEVER IN CALIFORNIA
THERE IS NO INSTITUTIONALIZED
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES WHICH OVERSEES
MEDICARE NOW IN THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
COORDINATE HEALTH SERVICES
DELIVERED THROUGH SCHOOLS. SB
FIVE SIXTY THREE WOULD
ESTABLISH AN OFFICE OF SCHOOL
BASED HEALTH PROGRAMS WITHIN
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO ENSURE GREATER
ACCESS TO HEALTH SERVICES AT
SCHOOLS AND HOPEFULLY THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT EVERYBODY CAN
SUPPORT DRAW DOWN OF MORE
FEDERAL FUNDS THE COBY NINETEEN
PANDEMIC HAS EXACERBATED
INEQUITIES IN HEALTH AND
EDUCATION AND AS THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS STATES IS INCREASE THE
NEED FOR SCHOOL BASED HEALTH
AND MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. AND I BELIEVE WE HAVE-
JASON CHAN FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF STUDENT COUNCILS
AND LISA EISENBERG THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BASED HEALTH
ALLIANCE IS AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. GREAT
THANK YOU MISTER BERMAN WERE
THEY GOING TO PRESENT AT ALL I
BELIEVE ON THE BILL OR THEY
JUST THERE FOR I THINK JASON
CHAN IS GOING TO PRESENT. MR
CHAN. YEAH FIVE GOOD MORNING
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS JASON CHAN I'M A HIGH
SCHOOL SENIOR OUT OF LAW HIGH
COMPARED WITH CISCO. AND I
REPEAT THAT THE CALIFORNIA
DIVISION. CAL TOLD THEM WE'RE
PROUD CO SPONSOR OF AB FIVE SIX
THREE- I DO BEGIN REOPENING
SCHOOL. RETURNING TO NEAR
NORMAL THING WE REALLY NEED TO
ADDRESS THE HEALTH NEEDS OF ARE
YOU. WHERE THEY ARE. AT SCHOOL.
AND THE MOST IMPORTANT TAKE
AWAY FROM THE PANDEMIC IS THAT.
FEWER STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS TO
QUALITY HEALTHCARE- FOR MANY
STUDENTS THE ISOLATION FROM
PEERS FAMILIES. AND SCHOOL
STAFF OVER THE LAST YEAR. HAVE
DEVASTATED THEIR MENTAL HEALTH
AND SOCIAL EMOTIONAL WELLNESS.
NATIONWIDE OVER ONE IN FIVE YOU
HAVE DIAGNOSABLE EMOTIONAL
MENTAL. OR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DISORDERS NOW INCREASE. DUE TO
COVER NINETEEN. SO SCHOOL BASED
HEALTH SERVICES SUCH AS HEALTH
EVALUATION BUT MENTAL HEALTH.
COUNSELLING SERVICE WOULD MEET
THE NEEDS. AND HAVE THE ADDED
BENEFIT OF PROVIDING. BEING
PROVIDED AT THE SCHOOL CAMPUS
WHICH IS AN ENVIRONMENT THAT
STUDENTS ARE MOST COMFORTABLE
WITH. CALIFORNIA MUST MAXIMIZE
THE ACCESSIBILITY ANDEQUITY.
OF SCHOOL BASED HEALTH
SERVICES. AND AB FIVE SIX THREE
JOHN DOES JUST THAT BY
CREATING. THE OFF OF THE SCHOOL
BASED HEALTH PROGRAMS AT THE
CDC- THE OFFICE WILL PLAY A
VITAL ROLE IN ENSURING
COORDINATED. WHICH TO FIFTH IN
MEETING THE INCREASED THE NEED.
AND WHILE THE STUDENT HEALTH.
AND MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS ARE MET
THERE WILL BE DRAMATICALLY
BETTER OUTCOMES INCLUDING HARD
TO ATTENDANCE WHICH MEANS
HIGHER FUNDING. AND BETTER
ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT. AGAIN
WE'D LIKE TO THANK THE TOTAL
NUMBER BERMAN FOR CHECKING THIS
BILL AND POWER. UNIT THE JOINT
THAT OFFERS. AS WELL CHAIRMAN
O'DONNELL FOR HEARING THIS BILL
BECOMING A JOINT AUTHORS-
RESPECTFULLY ASK. ABOUT THANK
YOU CHAN MR IS YOU YES AN HOUR
I WAS IN. SO I IS AS WE AND
THEN SHE ALSO A- THING
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS UNDERSTOOD.
MISS EISENBERG. GOOD MORNING
SHARING COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
ADAM. AND I THE PULSE DIRECTOR
THE CAL. SCHOOL BASED HOTLINE I
WILL KEEP IT VERY BROUGH. AND
SEE IF CAN END UP. BECAUSE
SPONSOR OF AB FIVE SIX THREE
HELLO WITH THAT. SCHOOL BOARDS
IT SAYS. CAL SCHOOL NURSE ORGAN.
CALIFORNIA TEACHER OF THOSE.
TEACHER FOR HEALTHY KIDS AND OF
COURSE THE CAL. AT THE- OF.
COUNT WE WITH OUR SPONSORS WITH.
BELIEVE THERE NEEDS TO BE
INCREASED CAPACITY AT EACH
PARTNER AND COLLABORATE WITH
EACH YEAR AND WEBER JEAN
MEDICARE REIMBURSEMENT CRITICAL
HEALTH SERVICES. AND ENSURE
THAT THERE'S GREATER ACCESS. TO
THE SERVICES IN OUR SCHOOLS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
IT'S- AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS AND ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE IN SUPPORT OF AB
FIVE SIX THREE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISS EISENBERG- WE WILL NOW
GO TO- ANY OPPOSITION IS ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. SENIOR
HEARING NO OPPOSITION WILL GO
TO THE COMMITTEE TO GATHER ANY
COMMENTS OR ANY THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. SINGLE COMMENTS MISTER
BENNETT I APPRECIATE THE
GETTING- THE OPPORTUNITY GET
THE FEDERAL FUNDING THANK YOU.
THANK THEM THANK MISTER BENNETT
ANY FURTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE SINGLE FURTHER FOR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE DO
WE HAVE A MOTION. IT'S BEEN
MOVED. MR BACK IN MISTER
BENNETT SECONDS I WOULD THAT
WILL GO TO THE PUBLIC WE'RE
GONNA OPEN THE FINAL PHONE
LINES FOR TEN MINUTES WE'LL
HEAR OPPOSITION AND SUPPORT. ON
THE SAME LINE. AB SO MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE LINES IF
YOU ARE ON THE PHONE WE- WE EAT
WHAT YOU MAY DO NOW AS YOU MAY-
SHARE YOUR OPINION OF THE BILL-
THAT SAID SUPPORTER OPPOSITION.
NO NO MORE DETAIL THAN THAT YOU
STATE YOUR NAME AFFILIATION IF
YOU'RE AFFILIATED WITH AN
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ON
THE BILL ONLY ANYTHING OTHER
THAN THAT THE MODERATOR WILL
IMMEDIATELY CUT YOU OFF. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU TO STATE YOUR
POSITION ON AB FIVE SIXTY THREE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE. AGAIN THE
COMMANDOS ONE TALIBAN ZERO.
WE'LL GO FIRST TO LINE NUMBER
THIRTY FIVE THREE FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YOU'RE ON THIRTY
FIVE IS YOUR PERSONAL DEVICE-
YOU. HELLO ARBEL COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JOHN
CONTRACTS I AM OF I AM AND I
THINK IT AT FIRST CUSTOMERS
THAT. WILL CALIFORNIA. I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR. ALL MARKET
DATA IS STRONG SUPPORT A- FIVE
SIX THREE NEVER ACCEPT ONLY I
THANK YOU. OUR NEXT FROM FOR
TWO FOR TWO YEAR LONG OPEN.
MISTER PENA. WHEN WE MOVED TO
THE NEXT LINE FORTY TWO WERE
YOU ON MUTE THANK YOU BYE IN
TWENTY THREE TO THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR TONY
TRIBBLE AERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION. CO SPONSOR AND
SUPPORTER OF AB FIVE SIX THREE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. TURNING
ON THE- LINE THIRTY THREE
THIRTY THREE THREE THE LINE IS
OPEN. THE MORNING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND SHARE THE THINKING
AND YOU'RE CALLING IN FROM THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SUCH
WORKERS PROPER CHAPTER PROUD
SPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. BY IN FORTY NINE
FOUR NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THE MORNING THIS IS DANIELLE
MAILLET WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LINE BOB FAMILY SERVICES IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NINE FIFTY
ONE FIVE ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FIVE ONE ARE YOU ON MUTE. WHAT
ONLINE FIFTY FIVE ZERO. GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING CATHY SURE
ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
WE'LL GO NEXT TO LINE THIRTY
FOUR THREE FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LIMIT ONE REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL NURSES
ORGANIZATION WE ARE PROUD CO
SPONSOR I'M ALSO- GIVING
SUPPORT FOR THE AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS WHO ARE
IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
FIVE SIXTY THREE THANK. NINE
FORTY FOUR ZERO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ERICA HOFFMAN ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION AT THE CO SPONSOR
OF THE MEASURE IN VERY MUCH IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE SIXTY THREE
THANK YOU. FINE NINE FORTY
SEVEN. I APOLOGIZE AT THIS TIME
THERE ARE NO FURTHER LINES IN
Q. THANK YOU OR GO BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE WILL ALREADY- TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION HEARD FROM
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS- WE HAVE
A MOTION. AND A SECOND- THE
MOTION IS- SUPPORT- TO PASS THE
TO DO HAS AMENDED HEALTH I'M
SORRY TO PASS AS AMENDED HELD
IS THE MOTION- SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO HEALTHCARE
DONALD FIVE. HIGHLY SENATE HI
DALLY LEAVE. MCCARTY QUIRK
SILVA. THAT'S FIVE YES FIVE OH
TO THAT THE BILL IS OUT MISTER
BERMAN THANK YOU MUCH WELL NOW
THAT'S A FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE-
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CRISTINA
GARCIA. YOU MAY PERCEIVE AND
READY. GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
MEMBERS WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS- THAT ARE
OUTLINED ON PAGE THE OF THE
ANALYSIS ON A THING STAFF WERE
WORKING ON THIS AB THREE SIXTY
SEVEN WERE BUILT ON PREVIOUS
WORK WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON TO-
INCREASE ACCESS TO MENSTRUAL
PRODUCTS TO REMOVE BARRIERS IS
THE INPUT THAT THE PART OF
SOCIETY MEN STRAIGHT
SPECIFICALLY THE BILL WOULD
REQUIRE ALL SCHOOLS MAINTAINING
GRADES SIX THROUGH TWELVE.
COMMUNITY COLLEGES COMMUNITY
CAMPUSES AND STATE LOCAL
MUNICIPAL ABILITY TO STOP IT
PUBLIC RUSSIAN FOR FREE
MENSTRUAL PRODUCTS- FOLLOWING
THE LEAD OF SCOTLAND WHO
ADOPTED THIS IS THE RIGHT LAST
YEAR. I HAD WITH ME I HAVE
PROUD SPONSORS THE STUDENT.
CALIFORNIA'S DECISION A SITTING
COUNCIL ACLU CALIFORNIA PERIOD.
THE MINISTER MOVE AND THE
ALLIANCE FOR GIRLS. AND THE
CALIFORNIA LATINAS FOR
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU WILL NOW GO TO
YOUR WITNESSES I BELIEVE AGAIN
JASON CHAN. FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOLS OF
STUDENT COUNCILS MR CHEN WHEN
IS IN SUPPORT. HI HI AGAIN-
THANK YOU- MISTER CHAIR- WE ARE
A PROUD SPONSOR OF AB THREE SIX
SEVEN AS YOU MAY REMEMBER
STUDENTS FROM ORGANIZATION
DEVELOP THIS PROPOSAL- TO YOUR-
ONE YEAR AGO AND IN TWENTY
TWENTY FOR THE FROM THE
COMMITTEE AND NOW WE'RE VERY
HAPPY THAT- AND THANKFUL THAT
AFFORDABLE GARCIA HAVE BEEN
CHAMPIONING- THIS REQUEST-
JUSTIN JUSTIN BASIC. GROUND TO
COVER- THE COMMITTEE PASSED AB
TEN AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN WHICH
REQUIRED ALL TITLE ONE SCHOOLS
PROVIDE FREE NATURAL PRODUCTS
TO THEIR STUDENTS THE THING IS
YOU KNOW AS AS EXCELLENT AS
THAT IS THAT IT DOESN'T COVER
IMPORTANT POPULATIONS WERE
FALLING THROUGH THE CRACKS
NUMBER ONE. IT DOESN'T COVER
STUDENTS WHO DON'T ATTEND A
TITLE ONE SCHOOL WHERE IN
CALIFORNIA 25% OF STUDENTS WHO
LIVE BELOW THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LINE DON'T ATTEND A TITLE ONE
SCHOOL- BILL CLINTON COVER-
MENTORING INDIVIDUALS- IN THE
IN COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES AS
WELL AS THE GENERAL PUBLIC WERE
ONE IN SIX. WOMEN CALIFORNIA
LIVE BELOW THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LINE AS WELL AB THREE SIX SEVEN
SIX OF THIS PROBLEM BY
PROVIDING FREE MENSTRUAL
PRODUCTS IN SCHOOLS COMMUNITY
COLLEGES DO YOU AND PUBLIC
BUILDINGS WE KNOW THAT THE
SOLUTION WORKS AND WHITE IN NEW
YORK CITY- THEY RAN A PILOT
PROJECT PROVIDING FREE PERIOD
PRODUCTS IN THEIR SCHOOL
INDEPENDENT INCREASED BY TWO
POINT FOUR PERCENT. NEW YORK
STATE HAS ALSO PASSED THE LAW
EXPANDING IT TO ALL PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AS WELL- IN IN REGARDS
TO COST I ALSO WANT TO POINT
OUT THAT FIFTY NINE SCHOOLS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE TRYING ONE. LEAD
HOLD ALREADY ARE REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE FREE NATURAL PRODUCTS
ARE ONLY TALKING ABOUT 41% OF
SCHOOLS THAT AREN'T MANDATED BY
LAW TO PROVIDE FINANCIAL
PRODUCTS- IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
WE WERE THE FIRST IN THE
COUNTRY THE PASSED THE LAW-
WITH AB TEN BUT NOW WE'RE
BEHIND THE CURVE. FOR OTHER
STATES HAVE PASSED LAWS AND WE
NEED THE CAR UP. YOU KNOW THIS
IS REALLY ABOUT THE AND DIG. OF
LOW INCOME- ONE. JEFF GENERAL
BINDER FOLKS AND ALL OF THE WHO
MANAGED- IT'S A- NEED AT THE Q.
RIGHTS- FROM THE PER. OF A NON
INDIVIDUAL YOU KNOW I IMAGINE
GOING TO THE BATHROOM HAVING TO
PAPER. AND EXACTING. WELL FOR
MENTORING AND- WHERE IT'S KIND
OF AND- IT IS AN IT DOESN'T-
PROCESS THAT- AND A- HUMANS.
THAT WE SHOULD STICK. FOR THESE
REASONS- WE URGE YOUR- I VOTE
TODAY- THANK YOU AGAIN FOR-
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS VIA FOR.
EMPOWERING YOUNG PEOPLE. ARE AT
THE FOREFRONT OF THIS
CONVERSATION. THANK YOU WILL
HAVE TO A MAY SAW IF I SAID
THAT BECAUSE I HOPE. SHE'S HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENT SAN MATTEO
COUNTY AMANDA. THE MORNING CARE
MANY MEMBERS MY NAME IS AMANDA
SOFTY AND I AND I. AGREE ON THE
BEST IN MY WORK THIS PAST YEARS
SPEARHEADING THE KERRY PROJECT
INFORMED THAT YOUR COMPANY I'VE
HAD A LOT OF CONVERSATIONS WITH
FRIENDS AND CLASSMATES ABOUT
OUR STRUGGLE WITH ACCESS TO.
PRODUCTS AT SCHOOL AND I WANT
TO SHARE ONE OF THEIR STORIES
TODAY. SO MY FRIEND GOT HER
PERIOD RIGHT BEFORE SHE HAD TO
TAKE A PHYSICS CLASS AND SHE
AFTER TEACHER TO USE THE
BATHROOM. AND THEN SHE REALIZED
THAT SHE DIDN'T HAVE ANY POTS
OR TAMPONS SHE WENT BACK TO
CAUTION SHOT COMFORTABLY AT HER
DESK AND SHE WAS UNABLE TO
CONCENTRATE ON OUR TAX. WELL
SHE BLOOD THROUGH HER PANTS IN
ONTO THE STREETS. AFTER THE
BELL RANG SHE HAD TO LEAVE
CAMPUS TO CHANGE YOUR
BLOODSTAINED PANTS AT HOME. AND
WHEN HER MOM CALLED THE OFFICE
SIX HER LEAVING SCHOOL THE
OFFICE MARCH MY FRIEND OPTIONS
AS A CAT INSTEAD OF EXCUSE ME
AS AN- EVERY TIME I WOULD HEAR
ONE OF THESE STORIES MY HEART
WITH EIGHT BECAUSE IT USUALLY
RESULTED. ACTUATOR FORCED TO
USE ON SENATE MILLION. NOTHING
EXCESSIVE FOR APPROX OR JUST
LEAVING SCHOOL AND HOW. MENTION
IT IS LIKE BEING ON MYSELF LIVE
AND BREATHE THE- STATE ACT
SINGLE DAY THAT WE STOP AND A
COUPLE BATH THAT DOES NOT HAVE
FREE PERIOD PRODUCTS. WE SHOULD
BE TALKING ABOUT THE. PRODUCTS
THE SAME WAY THAT WE STOCK THEM
WITH FREE TO PAPER. DISPATCH
DURING THE PANDA'S. IT SHOULD
BE A PART OF THE CULTURE AND
CLIMATE OF LOS. AND OUR CALL
SHOW USED. ONCE IS A NORMAL AND
NOT. PART OF OUR BY. AND I VOTE
EIGHTY SIXTY SEVEN TO NOT. AND
ONLY VENTURA IS BUT ALSO A
STATES ACROSS THE THAT MENTION.
MATTER AND I'VE ON EIGHTY TWO
SIXTY THREE WHAT ALSO MAKE HOW.
LEGAL STATE AND- BY THINKING IT.
IN AMERICA. THANK YOU. THANK A
WELL DONE BY WITH THAT IS THERE
OF. TO IF THREE SIX SEVEN-
HEARING OFFICE. ALL BRING BACK
THE COMMITTEE- ANY TWENTY
COMMON AB THREE SIX SEVEN A-
ESCORT SILVA. YEAH I JUST WANNA-
CONGRATULATE MINE ASSEMBLY
COLLEAGUE ON THIS BILL I HAVE
SEEN FIRSTHAND BEING ON
CAMPUSES. AND MEETING WITH SOME
OF THE YOUNG GIRLS GROUPS IN MY
DISTRICT TO. HAVE BEEN INSPIRED
BY THIS AND IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT
INSPIRATION BUT IT'S BETTER
DALY- ACTUALLY FAX THAT WOMEN
IT DID GO THROUGH EVERY MONTH
AND THIS IS A HUGE SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THE MINIMUM IS A
LITTLE. IT'S BEEN MOVED AND-
SECONDED BY MISTER BENNETT OF
ANY FURTHER COMMITTEE COMMON.
SENIOR FURTHER COMMITTEE
COMMENT ON THE BILL I JUST
WANNA THANK YOU FOR THE BILL AS
ONE WITH TWO DAUGHTERS THAT ARE
IN HIGH SCHOOL AND ONE HAS
TAUGHT MIDDLE AND HIGH SCHOOL I
KNOW HOW IMPORTANT THIS IS SO I
VERY MUCH APPRECIATED I THINK
IT ACTUALLY HELPS SCHOOLS- BY
PLACING THIS REQUIREMENT ON
THEM. BY HELPING KIDS AND NOT
CREATING SITUATIONS THAT ARE
UNFORTUNATE OR HI EVERYONE A
LABEL AND SO THANK YOU MISS
GARCIA WHAT WE GO TO THE PHONES
NOW WILL TAKE TEN MINUTES- OF-
SUPPORT OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONES. YOU STATE YOUR NAME.
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL ONLY PLEASE. IT TO THE
STATE YOUR POSITION ON THIS
BILL YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD
ONCE AGAIN THAT'S ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. WE'LL GO FIRST TO LINE
THIRTY THREE THREE THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AND YOU'RE
CALLING IN THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
TOP POINT CHAPTER. IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU. NEXT WE
HAVE LINE FIFTY EIGHT FIVE
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
FIFTY EIGHT DID YOU WANT TO
SHARE YOUR- POSITION. THE LINE
TWENTY SEVEN TWO SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WHAT IS THIS JUNK
DURING THE OUTSTANDING NIGHT
NATIONAL AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB THREE SIXTY SEVEN
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT HOME
OF THE LINE FORTY EIGHT FOUR
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS ERIN
EVAN ON BEHALF OF NARAL PRO
CHOICE CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NINE FIFTY NINE FIVE NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS RON
WRAPPED FROM THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NEXT DEADLINE THIRTY
FOUR THREE FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THERE'S A LADY OF ONE WITH THE-
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL NURSES
ORGANIZATION AS WELL AS THE
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS
CALIFORNIA DIVISION IN STRONG
SUPPORT. NEXTRA COMMENT FROM
NINE THIRTY EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT
LET US OPEN. SENATE CONNECTION
FOR CHEN OF STUDENTS I SUPPORT.
REMOVE THE LINE THIRTY NINE
THREE NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE ANOTHER
COUPLE BILLION I'M
ADJOURNMENTS. I AM SUPPORT AND
WORK WITH MOTION. IN OUR LAST
COMMON IN QUEUES LINE FIFTY
EIGHT FIVE EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE POINT FIFTY DO YOU
WANT TO SHARE YOUR POSITION.
ALL CLOSE AT THIS TIME MISTER
CHAIR THEY'RE NOT FOR THE LINES
IN Q. THANK YOU OUR MODERATOR-
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE WE'VE HAD COMMITTEE
COMMENT TAKEN- THE- THE- PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THIS BILLS WE OWE
YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND HAS
BEEN SECONDED BY MISTER
BENNETT- SO THE MOTION IS- DO
PASS AS AMENDED HIGHER
EDUCATION. SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL YES TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO HIGHER EDUCATION
O'DONNELL HI. KILEY BENNETT BY.
DALLY I BELIEVE MCCARTY QUICK
SILVA. HE HAS FIVE VOTES THE
BILL HAS FIVE OH TWO IT IS OUT
MISTER C. THANK YOU WITHOUT
WILL PROCEED AB ONE OF FOUR
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX BY- MISS
GONZALEZ- MAY PROCEED WHEN
READY FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AND THANK YOUR STAFF FOR
WORKING SO CLOSELY WITH MINE ON
THIS BILL OVER THE LAST FEW
MONTHS- GLAD WE CAN FINALLY
HEAR THIS PIECE OF IT. I'M GLAD
THAT THE REST ALSO GOT THROUGH.
SO I DON'T THINK ESPECIALLY IN
THIS COMMITTEE WE NEED TO TALK
ABOUT HOW DEVASTATING LEARNING
LOSS HAS BEEN DURING THE
PANDEMIC. THE CHALLENGES THAT
STUDENTS FACE ESPECIALLY IN
SOME OF OUR COMMUNITIES WERE
CONNECTIVITY WAS INITIAL- THE
CHALLENGES WE FACE THAT A
HUNDRED THIRTY THOUSAND KIDS
JUST SIMPLY NEVER SHOWED UP- IT
AND THERE WAS LOTS OF KIDS IN
PRIVATE SCHOOLS WELL THIS ISN'T
JUST A PUBLIC SCHOOL ISSUE. SO
WE KNOW THAT THERE WERE KIDS
WHO EITHER VOTE PARTIAL
EDUCATIONS OR DIDN'T
COMPLETELY- GET WHAT THEY
NEEDED. AND WE DON'T WANT KIDS
TO SUFFER AS A RESULT WE WANT
TO HOLD THEM HARMLESS. SO THIS
BILL IS PRETTY SIMPLE GIVES
OPTIONS FOR PARENTS. TO BE ABLE
TO PURSUE GIVEN THE INDIVIDUAL
NEEDS OF THOSE STUDENTS. IT
ALLOWS THEM TO SEEK POSSIBLE
RETENTION- I KNOW THAT'S
CONTROVERSIAL BUT A PARENT
SHOULD KNOW HOW TO BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS. THE POSSIBILITY OF
HOLDING A STUDENT BACK IF MAYBE
THEY GOT JUST NOTHING
UNFORTUNATELY COULD NEVER
REALLY GET ANYTHING ON THE ON
MY EDUCATION. WE KNOW THAT'S
TRUE ESPECIALLY FOR SOME OF THE
SMALL ONES BUT PARENTS SHOULD
BE ABLE TO. REQUEST THAT IN AND
HAVE A- CONSULTATION WITH A
SCHOOL TEACHER TO SEE IF THAT'S
THE BEST OPTION FOR THE CHILD.
WE WANT- STUDENTS AND PARENTS
WHO. PERHAPS THEY JUST HAD A
TOUGH YEAR IN HIGH SCHOOL-
COULDN'T LEARN SPANISH ONLINE.
GOTTA SEE OTHERWISE WAS ON ON
ON- THE ROTATE TO GETTING INTO
IT YOU SEE. I WOULD LIKE TO
pPASS OF DOESN'T HURT THEIR GPA
OVERALL. I'M OBVIOUSLY THE UC
AND CSU AS THEY SEE THESE WILL
KNOW THAT THE STUDENT PROBABLY
HAD SOME STRUGGLES I'M SURE
EVERYBODY'S AS HE'S GETTING TO
THE SCHOOL NEXT YEAR WE'LL TALK
ABOUT THEIR STRUGGLES- BUT IT
ALLOWS THEM. TO STAY IN THE
RANGE OF EIGHTY A OF A GRADE
POINT AVERAGE WHICH IS
INCREASINGLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE
THEY DON'T HAVE AN S. A. T. TO
SHOW THAT THEY CAN MAKE IT TO
SCHOOL WITHOUT BEING- HELD
ACCOUNTABLE ARE TO ACCOUNTABLE
FOR. A SITUATION THAT WAS
BEYOND THEIR CONTROL ARE THEY
COULD LEARN AND THAT KIND OF.
ATMOSPHERE THIS ALSO ALLOWS
FOR- BEYOND FOURTH YEAR OF
CREDIT RECOVERY SO THAT WE CAN
ENSURE THAT STUDENTS WHO. YOU
KNOW ESPECIALLY OUR JUNIORS AND
SENIORS WHO WHO MAYBE MISSED A
LITTLE TOO MUCH CAN STILL
GRADUATE. FROM HIGH SCHOOL WITH
A- HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA WHICH WE
KNOW IS SUPER AND- SO. THIS
JUST PROVIDES CHOICE. AND
OPTIONS UP PARENTS SINCE. AND
ALLOWS THEM. TO BE ABLE TO LOOK
AT THE SITUATION THAT THEIR OWN
FAMILY WENT THROUGH. AND SEE IF
THERE ARE WAYS TO HOLD- HOLD
THEM HARMLESS BASICALLY OUR
STUDENTS. SO WITH THAT I WILL I
KNOW WE HAVE A STUDENT- TO
TESTIFY IT'S A- GREAT THANK YOU
YES WE HAVE LEISHA MARTINEZ
SHE'S A HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT
FROM CORONA NORCO UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT SAFEST. MORNING
TERMINAL DONALD AND THE MEMBERS
OF THE ASSEMBLY EDUCATION
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS LISA
MARTINEZ AND I'M A SIXTEEN YEAR
OLD JUNIOR FROM THE CURRENT
MARKET UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
I WANTED TO TALK TODAY ABOUT MY
EXPERIENCE OF THE STUDENT GOING
TO CALL THAT. I'D LIKE TO START
OFF BY SAYING I AM THE OLDEST
CHILD AND MY MOTHER'S A SINGLE
PARENT AFTER MY STEPFATHER GOT
DEPORTED AROUND THE BEGINNING
OF THE PANDEMIC. I'VE HAD TO
TAKE ON A LOT OF RESPONSIBILITY
BUT THE BECOME THE MAN CARE
CAREGIVER FOR MY LITTLE. MY
LITTLE SISTER. I HAVE TO MAKE
SURE GETS. READY IN THE MORE.
GOES AND AS WELL. BUT SEMESTER
I SHARE THE CHROMEBOOK WITH MEL
SUBJECT WE CAN ONLY HAD ONE TO
BE AND I PRIORITIZE LEARNING
OVER MINE BUT COGNITIVE. BOB ON
MY OWN LEARNING. EVEN THOUGH I
OF STRUGGLE OF INTERNET BE ABLE
TO GRANT OF THE PER DURING THE
PANDEMIC I REALLY. AT WITH MY
SISTER MY HAVE SHOWN. THE HAVE
THE REALLY OF SISTER I. HAVE A
REALLY WITH MY TEACHERS I'M
VERY. I THINK SUPPORT THE MOST
THEY CAN. THE BILL. ONE OH FOUR
WOULD. BEGIN HAWKINS. DOCTOR
JOHN TIMES. KIND OF. I'M HERE.
CONSIDERING RETAKING JUNIOR
YEAR I FEEL I CAN PICK UP THE
MEASURE. A OF THE ACT. WITH I
BY. OF THE STATE WANTING TO GO
TO COLLEGE WITH THE PATH OF THE-
AND TAKING FIVE YEARS OF HIGH
SCHOOL. I WOULD NEED ENSURE
THAT WOULD BE ABLE TO GRADUATE.
THE FIRST PERSON TO MAKE A TO
GO TO CALL AND FOR. I WOULD ON
A LET DOWN FOR MEMBERS FRIENDS.
AND TO HAVE ENCOURAGED TO
PURSUE A AND- SHE KNOWING THAT.
I KNOW THAT YOU HOLDS ACCOUNT
UNACCOUNTABLE FOR WHAT GOING ON
AND CALIFORNIA NEED TO I'M NOT
BEEN FOR THE TIME AND OF THE
CODE NINETEEN PANDA BACKED BY
STUDENTS FAMILIES BUT MANY OF
OUR- BUT POINT THEIR END OF
LEARNING. EXACTLY I GETTING
HELP I AFTER ABLE AB ONE OF
FOUR. THANK YOU. GREAT THANK
YOU. IN A OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. WE HAVE NO OPPOSITION
WITNESSES FOR THE MUSCLES IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ALL TO
SAVE HER MY PERSPECTIVE- ALSO
GREAT BILL I THINK PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITY I'M PARTICULAR I
APPRECIATE YOUR FOCUS NOT ONLY
ON CREDIT RECOVERY BUT GREAT
RECOVERY. YES I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING HE'LL THINK OF OUT OF
THE GATE AS A HIGH SCHOOL
TEACHER IDEA AND THAT YOU
MENTION THE STUDENT HAS BEEN ON
ON THE RIGHT TRACK AND THEN
KIND OF FELL OFF THE GPA TRACK
AND BE GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY TO
GO PASS FAIL VERY IMPORTANT-
SO- THANK YOU WITH THAT ANY
OTHER- CONSOLINI COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. MISS WORK SELDOM. YEAH
I APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
THINKING ABOUT IN THIS COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC REALLY HIT
HISTORIC TIMES WAYS TO. CREATE
INTERVENTIONS FOR STUDENTS THAT
CAN ALLOW THEM TO GET BACK ON
TRACK. I SUPPORT THE BILL. MY
ONLY CAUTION WOULD BE-
PARTICULARLY FOR YOUNGER
STUDENTS BUT REALLY ALL
STUDENTS WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
WRITTEN TENSION IT HAS TO ONLY
BE IN THE MOST. A NARROW TERMS.
I AND I APPRECIATE THE PARENTS
HAVING THE OPPORTUNITY TO WEIGH
IN ON THIS. BECAUSE ALL TOO
OFTEN OVER DECADES OF TEACHING
MANY TIMES RETENTION. DOESN'T
WORK AND IF YOU. CONSIDER THAT
ALONG WITH CHILDREN THAT ARE
GOING THROUGH TRAUMA OF THE
PANDEMIC BEING RETAINED IN
ADDITION COULD BE. VERY VERY
DIFFICULT BUT- WE CERTAINLY
HAVE TO DO EXTRAORDINARY THINGS
IN A TIME THAT HAS BEEN
EXTRAORDINARY. SO I THINK YOU
BRING IT FORWARD AND I SUPPORT
THE BILL. THANK YOU. BOB
STARTING WITH THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR I'VE ZOOMED WITH. ALL OF
US HAVE WITH HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS THAT IN THEIR JUNIOR
YEAR SPECIFICALLY WHICH IS THE
BIGGEST YEAR OF AIR LOOKING AT
YOUR CREDITS AND WE'RE GOING TO
APPLY SO I THINK YOU FOR THIS
BECAUSE THESE KIDS HAVE JUST
BEEN ROCKED THEY DON'T KNOW
WHAT'S NEXTINGRATE STUDENTS ON
TRACK LIKE YOU SAID TO
UNIVERSITY JUST DROPPED OFF
BECAUSE WHAT WAS THE
MOTIVATION. SO THANK YOU THIS
IS CREATIVE AND- THANK YOU FOR
THE PARENTAL CHOICE. COMPONENT
AS WELL. THANK YOU. I KNOW FOR
THE COMING FROM THE COMMITTEE
WHEN WE GO TO THE PHONES WILL
TAKE TEN MINUTES. ON THE PHONE
FOR TEN MINUTES ON THE PHONE.
THANK YOU TO STATE YOUR
POSITION ON AB ONE OFF FOR YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. BEGIN THE
COMMANDERS ONE AND THEN. ZERO
WE'LL GO FIRST TO LINE SEVENTY
ONE SEVEN ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING AARON AFTER A
COUPLE OF ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT
OF AB ONE OH FOUR THANK YOU.
NEXT WE HAVE LINE THIRTY EIGHT
THREE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
LINE THIRTY EIGHT ARE YOU ON
MUTE. MOVED ONLINE SEVENTY TWO
SEVEN TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS JASON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PERSISTENCE IN
CALPERS IN STRONG SUPPORT. NEXT
WE HAVE A COMMENT FROM SEVENTY
SEVEN NINE SEVEN SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THE MORNING LOOKS
SET A TOPIC WITH THE PARENT
INSTITUTE FOR QUALITY EDUCATION
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE OH
FOUR THANK YOU. ON THE LINE
THIRTY NINE THREE NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THE ONLY AND I'M
NOT STUDENTS AND PARENTS
SUPPORT OF AB ONE OF. FOR THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AT THIS TIME
THERE ARE NO FURTHER LINES IN
Q. THANK YOU LET'S BRING IT
BACK THEN I DO WE HAVE A MOTION
ON THIS. IT WILL MISS MCCARTY
MOOSE I MISS QUICK SILVA
SECONDS- WITH THAT- THE MOTION
IS. I DO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
JUNIOR DO PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS FOR THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE O'DONNELL I FOR DAHLE
AYE KILEY. KILEY I'D BENNETT
DOLLY. DALI I'D LEAVE MCCARTY
RIGHT MCCARTY I PURCHASED OVER.
PERKS SILVA I. THAT'S FIVE
VOTES BILLS OUT AS FIVE VOTES
THANK YOU MISS BECAUSE ALL WILL
NOT MOVE AB EIGHT MR MEDINA
WHERE'S MR MEDINA. YEAH.
THAT
NUMBER.
IF YOU CAN. AFTER MR
MEDINA WILL GO TO MISS THREE OF
US BUT SHE MAY BE CHAIRING A
COMMITTEE THAT WILL GO TO
MISTER- SAY ARCO. SO INVESTORS
SAY ARE TO. STEP IN HERE AS
THEY MIGHT WANT TO HEAD UP THIS
WAY. I CAN'T.
NOT THINK ABOUT
NORMAL. WE ARE. YOU TALKING. MR
SAY ARTO COULD HEAD DOWN TO
HEAD UP TO THE COMMITTEE. RIVAS
THREE OF US SAYS CHAIRING A
COMMITTEE AT THIS MOMENT.
NEITHER AM SHOVEL GO TO MISS
QUICK SILVA IN A MOMENT. WHAT
IS THE BEST RESOURCE FOR THE-
SO. WELL I DON'T HAVE ALTHOUGH
THIS WORKS. WE'RE GOING MISS
CORK SILVA- SHE IS AB FIVE FIVE
TWO FILE ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN.
AFTER THAT WE'LL GO TO VENENO
DONALD. SO- WITH THAT- MISS
CORK SILVA. LET ME GET TO MY-
EVEY FIRST VIOLIN NUMBER
SIXTEEN AB FIVE FIVE TWO YOU
MAY PERCEIVE ALREADY. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I WANT
TO FIRST START BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH ME AND MY OFFICE ON THIS
BILL AND ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
FIVE TWO WOULD ALLOW WOULD NOT
REQUIRE SCHOOLS AND COUNTIES TO
ENTER INTO AT INTO THE
INTEGRATED SCHOOL BASED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAM. TO PROVIDE EARLY
INTERVENTION IN ACCESS TO
BEHAVIORAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FOR ALL STUDENTS. FIRE
TO THE PANDEMIC REPORTS HAVE
PROVIDED STARTLING INFORMATION
ON THE MENTAL HEALTH AND
BEHAVIOR LANDSCAPE OF SCHOOL
AGE CHILDREN AND YOUTH SCHOOLS
AND HOSPITALS HAVE SEEN A
STEADY RISE IN STUDENTS
SUFFERING FROM TRAUMA ANXIETY
DEPRESSION AND SUICIDAL
THOUGHTS OVER THE PAST FEW
YEARS. JUST AN EXAMPLE IN MY
DISTRICT ALONE TRACK COSTS FOR
ALL CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL OPENED
UP AN ANALYST ADOLESCENT WING
WHICH SOUNDS LIKE A- GREAT
ADDITION TO A CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL BUT WHEN YOU ASK WHY
IT'S EXACTLY I WAS AS WAS
STATED. YOUNG GIRLS AS YOUNG AS
THE AGE OF EIGHT BEING ADMITTED
FOR EATING DISORDERS CUTTING
AND OTHER SITUATIONS AND THIS
WAS BEFORE THE PANDEMIC. AS WE
ALL KNOW TOO WELL IN THIS
COMMITTEE COBIT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC HAS INTENSIFIED THIS
HEALTH CRISIS. STUDENTS HAVE
BEEN OUT OF SCHOOL SINCE LAST
MARCH THEY'VE SUFFERED FROM
ISOLATION ANXIETY AND OVER THE
UNCERTAINTY OF THE IMMEDIATE
AND LONG TERM FUTURE AND LACK
OF PEER SUPPORT AND CONCERNS
WITH FAMILY THAT. THEY AND
THEIR FAMILIES AND- WILL INDOOR
AND WHAT THIS WILL TAKE AS A
TOOL FOR THEIR FAMILIES. WITH
THIS WE KNOW THAT SCHOOLS HAVE
ASKED FOR SUPPORT AND NOT
ALWAYS KNOWING HOW TO NAVIGATE
THE MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM MANY
TIMES. THE STUDENTS HAVE NOT
BEEN REFERRED AS A STATE WE
MUST DO WHAT WE CAN TO ADDRESS
THE NEEDS OF OUR STUDENTS AND
TO REAP. BELIEVE SOME OF THE
PRESSURE AT SCHOOLS BY ALLOWING
APPROPRIATE COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS A COUNTY
BEHAVIOR HEALTH AGENCIES TO
PROVIDE BEHAVIORAL AND MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ON SCHOOL SITES
IF NEEDED. WITH ME TODAY VIA
PHONE TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY AND
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS TO THE
COMMITTEE WE HAVE. DR SAND OF
ALL WHO IS THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF BEHAVIOR HEALTH CLUB IN
CHILD AND ADOLESCENT SERVICES
WITH THE MONTEREY COUNTY HEALTH
DEPARTMENT. I WAS AT MY JOB
YOUR JOB THAT'S GOING TO GO
AHEAD OF DOCTORS GENERAL
PROCEED. GOOD MORNING THANK YOU
FOR HAVING ME HERE- WITH THE
COMMITTEE I JUST WANTED TO
SHARE THAT THROUGH ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE FIVE TO SCHOOLS
PARTICIPATING IN THE
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM. I COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AGENCY
TRAINED PROFESSIONALS WILL
SERVE ANY STUDENT APPROPRIATELY
REFERRED BY SCHOOL PERSONNEL
INCLUDING MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES PRIVATELY INSURED
AND UNINSURED STUDENTS AND
PROVIDE BRIEF INITIAL
INTERVENTION SERVICES INTENDED
TO PREVENT A BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CONDITION FROM WORSENING. THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS WILL ENSURE
PRIVATELY INSURED STUDENTS
ACCESSED A PRIVATE PLAN
PROVIDER IS AVAILABLE IN A
LIMITED INSTANCES WHEN THE
PRIVATE PLANS CANNOT PROVIDE AN
APPROPRIATE PROVIDER WITHIN
STATE MANDATED TIMELY ACCESS
TIME FRAMES. THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AGENCY WILL
INITIATE SERVICES AS
APPROPRIATE AND CONSISTENT WITH
PROFESSIONALLY RECOGNIZED
STANDARDS OF PRACTICE. THE
INCREASING RATES OF MENTAL
HEALTH CHALLENGES THAT OUR
CHILDREN AND YOU HAVE BEEN
FACING HAS A DIRECT NEGATIVE
IMPACT ON OVERALL DEVELOPMENT
AND IMPEDES EVEN ABILITY TO
FULLY ACCESS THEIR EDUCATION.
THE SIGNIFICANT IMPACT OF THE
CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC WILL
ONLY ADD TO THE INCREASING
MENTAL HEALTH DIFFICULTIES. OUR
EDUCATORS ARE TASKED WITH THE
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT JOB OF
ENSURING OUR CHILDREN LEARN
UNFORTUNATELY MENTAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES CREATE BARRIERS TO
LEARNING FOR CHILDREN. AB FIVE
FIVE TWO WOULD PROVIDE THE
SUPPORT NECESSARY TO ALLOW OUR
EDUCATORS TO FOCUS ON THEIR
CRITICAL AREA OF EXPERTISE.
TEACHING OUR CHILDREN BY
BRINGING MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS INTO SCHOOLS TO
PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH
CONSULTATION AND SUPPORT TO
EDUCATORS AND TREATMENT TO THE
STUDENT. COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AGENCIES ARE UNIQUELY
POSITIONED TO PARTNER WITH
ELEAZAR AND BRING IN MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM OF CARE ARRAY OF
SERVICES TO SCHOOL CAMPUSES.
ENSURING EARLY IDENTIFICATION
AND TREATMENT OF CHILD AND
YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS. IN
MODERATE WE HAVE SUCCESSFULLY
CREATED SUCH PARTNERSHIPS
BETWEEN ELEAZAR AND COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH BRINGING THE
CRITICALLY NEEDED MENTAL HEALTH
CONSULTATION TO EDUCATORS AND
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES TO WHERE
THE CHILDREN ARE. ON THE SCHOOL
CAMPUS. AND DURING THIS CODE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC WE HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY PROVIDED ALL
SERVICES VIA TELEHEALTH
PLATFORM ENSURING THE
SUMMARIZING CAN YOU TO RECEIVE-
ENSURING THAT STUDENTS RECEIVE
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES THEY
NEED AB FIVE FIVE TWO WILL
ALLOW FOR ALL CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS TO HAVE MENTAL HEALTH
SUPPORTS NECESSARY TO FULLY GET
THEIR EDUCATION. GREAT WILL TO
GO YOUR NEXT WITNESS IN SUPPORT
BOB. I BELIEVE IT'S A DIAL ALL
SAY THE PRICES I HOPE I DO THIS
CORRECTLY SHEFALI JUST SAW.
FROM THE HATHAWAY SYCAMORES
CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES. YEAH
YOU GOT THAT RIGHT. NO DONALD
BY YOUR KILEY AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS THE POLITICS ARE
ASSISTANT VICE PRESIDENT OF
EARLY EDUCATION AND SCHOOL
BASED MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AT
HALFWAY SYCAMORES WE ARE A
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES A CO SPONSOR OF THE
BILL. ON BEHALF OF THE FIFTEEN
THOUSAND CHILDREN YOUNG ADULTS
AND ADULTS WHO WE SERVE
ANNUALLY I THINK THE COURT IS
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
FIVE IF YOU CURRENTLY HAVE A
PROGRAM THIRD STUDENTS IN OVER
THIRTY SCHOOL CAMPUSES AS A
RESULT OF MO USE WITH SIX LOCAL
SCHOOL DISTRICT. AND FIVE
CHARTER SCHOOL BURKE. AT THE
SPECIAL NUMBER. SERVING
ENTITLED MEDIC HOW- EARLY AND-
SCREENING. ENTRY SERVICE. WE
THINK THE LORD FOR BELIEVE ALSO
CONNECT. DO AND GETTING.
SERVICES THREE MORE. PROSPECTS
INCREASED AND- SYSTEM THAT ARE
SIMPLE NAVIGATE. UNDER THE-
SYSTEM IF THE IS ELIGIBLE FOR.
YES T. RECEIVE A CALL. SET OF.
AND CONTACT IF YOU WERE AND ARE
THERE. PRIVATE HEALTH PLAN
EVERY LIMITED. EIGHTY FIVE
FIFTY TWO WITHOUT WITH THE
INTEGRATOR WILL BE SPEAKING
ABOUT HOW PARTNERS PROGRAM.
THAT WE FACILITATE BECAUSE-
ACCORDING TO FURTHER CLOSE THE
GAP. MORE STUDENTS WHO NEED
MENTAL HEALTH. FOR ARE ABLE TO
ACCESS HERE. I WANT TO CLOSE
WITH AN EXAMPLE OF THE-
REFERRED BY CAPITAL UNIFIED FOR
THE- JOHN A SEVEN YEAR OLD
CLIENT IN HIS GRANT. HERE
GRANDFATHER CONTRACT COMPANY.
WE PHILOSOPHY. AND OUR TEAM. A
AND FAMILY THERAPY AT THIS THE
FAMILY AND ACT. REPORT LEGALIST.
SECTOR AND- WHAT THE- HE
HEATING AND GAP IN OUR HOME. WE
WERE ABLE TO. YOU SERVICE UNDER
MEDICARE YES KEEP YOUR PARTNER.
WITH THE FOR THE- AND L. A.
COUNTY DEPART. OF HEALTH.
ENCLOSING HAPPY SECOND STRONGLY
URGES ALL MEMBERS OF THE EXTENT
EDUCATE COMMITTEE TO ENJOY THE
FACT BILL FIVE FIFTY TWO. WHICH
CODIFIED PROGRAMMATIC BEST
PRACTICE. IN THE FOR OF THE
HAVE HEART FOR THE BIG. ANYHOW
IN NEED ON SCHOOL CAMPUS. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. OF ONE MOVES ANY
AND THERE'S NO OPPOSITE. IT
APPEARS. MINUTES. THANK YOU TO
STATE YOUR POSITION ON A. B.
FIVE FIVE TO ME PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO IF YOUR IN QUEUE FOR
DIFFERENT BILL YOU MAY REMOVE
YOURSELF BY REPEATING AND ONE
OF THEM ZERO AT THIS TIME. WELL
THE FIRST ONLINE THIRTY ONE YOU
WANT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SHARE
MEMBERS OF HIS VAN AND GO WITH
THE STANDARD ANSWER TO ARM. IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. NEXT WE
HAVE A COMMENT FROM LINE FORTY
FOUR FOUR FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO KAREN MEMBERS COUNCILLORS
FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION-
TAKEN A SUPPORTER FOR MANY
POSITIONS WE THANK THE AUTHOR
OFFICE FOR WORKING WITH US AS
THE BILL MOVES THANK YOU. NEXT
WE HAVE A COMMENT FROM LINE
EIGHTY FIVE EIGHT FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ADRIAN SHELTON
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF
CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES WE
ARE PROUD TO SPONSOR OF EIGHTY
FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
WE HAVE A COMMENT FROM LINE
FIFTY THREE FIVE THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. JOHN THE FACT THAT.
THEY ALSO HAVE A MOBILE. AS YOU
RECEIVED THOUSANDS THAT I
SUPPORT HIS BILL. NEXT WE HAVE
A COMMENT MIND SIXTY SIX SIX
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU EVERY A DAY AT HOME WITH
THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION THE OTHER
CRAP PROUD CO SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU. WE'LL GO NOW TO
LINE SIXTY NINE SIX NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS SHELLY
DO VERY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ACCESS COALITION AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE FIVE THANK
YOU. OUR NEXT COMMON IT'S ONE
THIRTY FOUR THREE FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AB ONE REPRESENTING
THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS CALIFORNIA DIVISION
WE ARE IN SUPPORT. NEXT WE HAVE
A COMMON FROM SIXTY ONE SIX ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE MORNING
SIGN IN THERE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY
BEHAVIOR HEALTH AGENCY AND WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE FIGHT
TO. OUR FINAL COMMENTING CUES
FROM LINE TWENTY THREE TO THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LINE TWENTY
THREE ARE YOU WANT ME. THANK
YOU STRUCTURE AT THIS TIME
THEY'RE NOT FOR THEIR LINES IN
Q. THANK YOU AYE MISFIRED AYE
WITH THAT- WILL BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE THERE HAS BEEN A
MOTION AND A SECOND- THE
EMOTION IS AS FOLLOWS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO HEALTH. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO HEALTH O'DONNELL
HI BUT DONALD HI KILEY KILEY
I'D BENNETT'S. DALI DALI I'D
LEAVE MCCARTY THANK MCCARTY HI
QUICK SILVA HI RICK SILVA HI
THAT HAS FIVE VOTES THE BILL'S
FIVE ALTERNATIVES OUT WE'RE NOW
GOING TO THANK YOU MISS WORK AT
ALL WE'RE NOT GOING TO MOVE TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. THREE OF US I
WILL HEAR AB. TWENTY SEVEN-
WHICH IS FUN NUMBER SEVENTEEN
AB TWENTY SEVEN YOU MAY
PERCEIVE ALREADY. GOOD
AFTERNOON GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- I WANT TO
START BY ACCEPTING THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS AND THANKING THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH ME ON THIS BILL. AB TWENTY
SEVEN IS THE REINTRODUCTION OF
LEGISLATION FROM LAST YEAR AND
CONTINUES TO ESTABLISH A
COMPREHENSIVE POLICY APPROACH
TO ASSIST LOCAL COMMUNITIES
TACKLING THE HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS. THE BILL ESTABLISHES A
STANDARDIZED PROCESS FOR
IDENTIFYING HOMELESS STUDENTS
THIS MEASURE ALSO CREATES THREE
GEOGRAPHICALLY LOCATED COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION TO DEVELOP
LOCAL TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
CENTERS TO IMPLEMENT BEST
PRACTICES USED IN IDENTIFYING
AND CONNECTING HOMELESS
STUDENTS. TO SERVICES. I AM
TODAY- TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT I HAVE WITH ME KATHY
RAYBURN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PARENT TEACHERS ASSOCIATION.
MORNING CATHY RENDON HERE FOR
CALIFORNIA STATE PTA PARENT
TEACHER ASSOCIATION I AM
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SEVEN WHICH IS THE
REASON TO INTRODUCTION OF AB
NINETEEN THIRTY SEVEN FROM LAST
YEAR AND IT'S YOURS THAT
SCHOOLS RECEIVE THE SUPPORT
THEY NEED TO FIGHT HOMELESSNESS.
CURRENTLY NO STANDARDIZED
PROCESS FOR IDENTIFYING
HOMELESS CHILDREN THIS BILL
AFFECTS THAT BY IDENTIFYING
HOMELESS CHILDREN THE STATE
CAN'T INSURE SPEEDY AND
DISTRICT HAVE THE ABILITY TO
DELIVER LIMITED RESOURCES MORE
EFFECTIVELY AT A TIME WHEN WE
NEED IT THE MOST. AB TWENTY
SEVEN WILL ALSO CREATE THREE
GEOGRAPHICALLY LOCATED COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION THROUGHOUT
THE STATE TO DEVELOP REGIONAL
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE CENTERS TO
IMPLEMENT BEST PRACTICES USED
FOR IDENTIFYING AND CONNECTING
HOMELESS STUDENTS AT THE-SERVICE AND- CALLED IT IS GOING
TO CAUSE EVEN HIGHER AMOUNTS OF
HOMELESS YEARS. IF WE CAN
IDENTIFY THESE KIDS WE CAN
CONNECT THEM AND THEIR FAMILIES
WITH EXISTING PROGRAMS THAT
PROVIDE SERVICES. THE AUDITOR
HAS INDICATED THAT TOO MANY
SCHOOLS ARE FAILING TO IDENTIFY
HOMELESS YOUTH BECAUSE OF
INCONSISTENT POLICY. OVER FOUR
HUNDRED SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE
FAILED TO IDENTIFY A SINGLE
HOMELESS STUDENTS SOMETHING
THAT IS THE ABSOLUTE
DERELICTION OF DUTY FOR US TO
HELP. THE HOMELESS YEARS. THE
AUDIT HIGH THE SCHOOL DAY NEEDS
IN THE BEST PRACTICES AND
REGIONAL TECHNO AT THIS CENTER
WILL PROVIDE CREEK CRITICAL
RESOURCES. IDENTIFYING CHILDREN
WHO MIGHT BE HOMELESS AS THE
FIRST STEP TO ENSURING THEY
HAVE A BY AND CYSTIC STAYED IN
SCHOOL AND LIFE BY ESTABLISHING
AND FINDING THE THREE COUNTRIES
COUNTY OFFICES OF THAT TO
DEVELOP TECHNICAL OFFENSE
DISTANCE CENTER THE STATE CAN
ASSIST LOCAL COMMUNITIES WHO
ARE TRYING TO TACKLE THE
GROWING HOMELESS CRISIS. BY
IMPLEMENTING IMPLEMENTING BEST
PRACTICES USED BY DENNIS FINING
CONNECTING HOMELESS STUDENT
THAT THE SERVICE. SERVICES IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN U. S.
CONGRESS PASSED THE MCKINNEY
VENTO HOMELESS ASSISTANCE ACT
TO ENSURE THAT ACCESS TO PUBLIC
EDUCATION THE ACT REQUIRED
STATES TO IDENTIFY AND PROVIDE
SERVICES TO HOMELESS CHILDREN
AND USE. THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF ED ADMINISTER THE
ACCIDENT OVERSEAS LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES WHICH ARE
REQUIRED TO WORK WITH STUDENTS
AND TO IDENTIFY HOMELESS
STUDENTS AND PROVIDE THEM WITH
SUPPORT CLEAR. SUMMARIZE ONE
TOP. WHAT LISA. OKAY OUR
SCHOOLS NEED FROM THE STATE THE
FIGHT HOMELESSNESS- THANK YOU
BASICALLY WE MIGHT BUILDER AND
THAT WE CARE THAT THEY MATTER
AND THAT WE WANT THEM TO SIXTY.
THANK YOU THERE ARE NONE MARTIN
PART AT. IF WHEN I GO TO YOUR
NEXT WITNESS IN SUPPORT TWO
MINUTES PLEASE TWO MINUTES
PLEASE EACH WITNESS- BRAND SAP
FROM THE AREA FROM-
SUPERINTENDENT THURMAN'S OFFICE.
I BELIEVE HE IS NOT AVAILABLE
NOT AVAILABLE NOT. AVAILABLE SO
WITH THAT WILL ANY I DON'T SEE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. ARE THERE ANY
COMMENTS READY THAT MANY
MEMBERS. I'M GLAD YOU OF WE'RE
NOT AMERICANS READY TO. BUT BUT
THANK ON IPHONES RIGHT NOW SO
MODERATOR IF WE COULD. JETAVANA
HER NOW PLEASE THANK YOU- ANY
COMMITTEE ANY ANY CONTRARY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SEEING OF
COMMENTATOR MR YARMOUTH OF THE
BILL AND AT JUST THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR PERSEVERANCE IS
ISSUES YOU KNOW. IS THAT OUR
HEARTS IN OUR TEENS PUTTING
MINE RIGHT HERE ITSELF THANK
YOU FOR STAYING AT TWENTY
AFRAID GIVEN MOVED AND SECONDED
BY MISS CORK SILVA SINGH OF
FURTHER COMMITTEE COMMENT- WE
WILL GO TO THE PHONES- TEN
MINUTES ON THE PHONES-
MODERATOR TO THE PHONE PLEASE.
DO YOU STATE YOUR POSITION ON
THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO USING YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD AGAIN THAT'S
ONE FALL BY ZERO. WE'LL GO
FIRST TO LINE A NUMBER NINETY
NINE NINE NINE NINE IS OPEN.
ERICA HOFFMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORTED THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU. MEXICANUM
NINE ONE OH FOUR ONE HUNDRED
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE'RE
BACK WITH HIM BOTH OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. FORTY THREE PLEASE
CHECK FOR ME. CAMBERLEY
ROSENBERGER WITH FSU
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
NEXT TRIP NINE ONE OH TWO ONE
HUNDRED TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GENEROUS THAT HOUSING
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANKS WE HAVE LINE ONE ONE ONE
HUNDRED ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
KATHY SURE WITH THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA AND. WE'LL GO TO
LINE THIRTY NINE THREE NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHAT HAPPENED
SOLELY WITH JONATHAN SUPPORT.
FIND ONE OLD THREE ONE HUNDRED
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS SHALL WE DO VERY WITH A
CALIFORNIA ACCENT COALITION AND
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE. NEXT IN LINE THIRTY
FOUR THREE FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. VIDEO OF ONE REPRESENTING
LURKING CANOPY THE ACTRESS
CALIFORNIA DIVISION WE ARE IN
SUPPORT. BUT A LINE ONE HUNDRED
ONE ZERO ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I KNEW WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY BEHAVIOR
HEALTH AGENCY AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT. HELLO OUR FINAL
COMMENTING CUES LINE SEVENTY
TWO SEVEN TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AND SEVENTY TWO NINETY ONE OF
STATE YOUR POSITION- HI- JUST
THE STATEMENT FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
COUNSELED IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ARE WITH THAT WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
THERE HAS BEEN A MOTION- THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
O'DONNELL I DON'T KNOW HI
KILEY. KILEY FIVE BENNETT. DELI
DELI I LEE MCCARTY RIGHT
MCCARTYI QUICK. QUIKSILVER I
HAS FIVE VOTES. THE BILL HAS
FIVE VOTES IT IS OUT. THANK
YOU. I WITH THAT WE'LL NOW MOVE
TO- AB ONE EIGHT ONE FIVE AB
EIGHT ONE FIVE FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHTEEN. YOU MAY PERCEIVE
ALREADY THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I WANT TO BEGIN BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR THOROUGH EVALUATION
OF THIS IMPORTANT BILL. AB
EIGHT ONE FIVE WOULD HELP
ALLEVIATE THE SCHOOL NURSE
SHORTAGE IN CALIFORNIA BY
CLARIFYING EXISTING LAW- BY
STATING THAT ELEAZAR ARE
AUTHORIZED TO OFFER IN HOUSE
SCHOOL NURSE CREDENTIALING
PROGRAMS TO QUALIFIED
CANDIDATES. COBIT NINETEEN
PANDA. HIGHLIGHTED THE CRITICAL
ROLE THAT NURSES PLAY IN
SAFEGUARDING OUR THE HEALTH OF
OUR COMMUNITIES UNFORTUNATELY A
MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
CHILDREN ATTEND THE SCHOOL
WITHOUT A NURSE PRESENT.
CALIFORNIA HAS ONE OF THE WORST
NURSE TO STUDENT RATIOS IN THE
COUNTRY WITH TWENTY FOUR
HUNDRED STUDENTS FOR EVERY
SCHOOL NURSE. THE SCHOOL NURSE
SHORTAGE IS PARTICULARLY
CONCERNING AS CHRONIC HEALTH
CONDITIONS AMONG STUDENTS SUCH
AS CHILDHOOD OBESITY AND ASTHMA
CONTINUE TO RISE WITHOUT SCHOOL
NURSES NON MEDICAL SCHOOL STAFF
MUST PROVIDE CRITICAL HEALTH
SERVICES THAT STUDENTS NEED.
INCLUDING ADMINISTERING INSULIN
MODERATE SIGNIFICANT ALLERGIES
AND ASSISTING STUDENTS WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS. UNDER CURRENT
LAW A CANDIDATE WHO WANTS TO
BECOME A SCHOOL NURSE MUST HOLD
A BACHELOR'S DEGREE AND A
NURSING LICENSE IN ADDITION
SCHOOLERS CANDIDATES MUST
COMPLETE AN ADDITIONAL YEAR OF
COURSE WORK TO RECEIVE A CLEAR
SCHOOL NURSE SERVICES.
CREDENTIAL HOWEVER ONLY FOR
UNIVERSITIES IN THE ENTIRE
STATE CURRENTLY OFFER PROGRAMS
THAT CAN GRANT THIS THE NURSE
SERVICES CREDENTIAL. AB EIGHT
ONE FIVE CREATES AN ADDITIONAL
PIPELINE FOR SCHOOL NURSE
CANDIDATES TO RECEIVE THIS
CREDENTIAL BY ALLOWING ELEAZAR
TO OFFER IN HOUSE CREDENTIALING
PROGRAMS. THESE ALLEY A
SPONSORED PROGRAMS WOULD HAVE
TO BE APPROVED BY THE
COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING. AT THIS TIME I
WOULD LIKE TO TURN IT OVER TO
DR BRIAN JOHNSON DIRECTOR OF
HUMAN RESOURCES AT THE LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. AND COLLEEN JOHNSON
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENTS
EDUCATIONAL SERVICES
ASSOCIATION. DOCTOR JOHNSON YOU
MAY PROCEED. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR O'DONNELL MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND STAFF MY NAME IS
DR BRIAN JOHNSON AND I
CURRENTLY SERVE AS DIRECTOR SHE
DID BEGIN WORKFORCE MANAGEMENT
FOR THE LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT WE ARE PLEASED
TO SPONSOR ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
ONE FIVE AS AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THREE OF US.
NOW MORE THAN EVER SCHOOL
NURSES ARE CRITICAL MEMBERS OF
OUR SCHOOL COMMUNITIES AND
THERE ARE SEVERAL BARRIERS THAT
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES
EXPERIENCE WHEN WORKING TO
RECRUIT AND RETAIN SCHOOL
NURSES. ONE AVERAGE OF NEARLY
FOUR HUNDRED PRELIMINARY SCHOOL
NURSE SERVICES CREDENTIALS HAVE
BEEN ISSUED IN EACH OF THE LAST
FIVE YEARS ONLY ABOUT ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY CLEAR SCHOOL
NURSE SERVICE CREDENTIALS HAVE
BEEN ISSUED PER YEAR ON
AVERAGE. DURING THAT SAME TIME
PERIOD. THERE IS A SERIOUS
RETENTION GAP FOR SCHOOL NURSES
A GAP THAT MANIFESTS ITSELF IN
OUR ELEAZAR SCHOOLS AND WITH
OUR CHILDREN. WHAT DENTAL OF
UNIFIED VIEWS EIGHTY EIGHT ONE
FIVE AS A MEANS TO CREATE AN
ALTERNATIVE OPTION TO BUT NOT A
REPLACEMENT FOR. THE EXISTING
CLEAR CREDENTIALING PROGRAMS
OFFERED BY POST SECONDARY
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION. WE BELIEVE AB EIGHT
ONE FIVE WILL INCREASE ACCESS
TO HIGH QUALITY CREDENTIALING
PROGRAMS AND WILL SUPPORT THE
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION OF
QUALIFIED SCHOOL NURSES ACROSS
THE STATE. WE RECENTLY SURVEYED
ABOUT ONE HUNDRED AND NINETY
MEMBERS OF OUR SCHOOL NURSE
WORKFORCE WHO ARE CURRENTLY
SERVING UNDER PRELIMINARY
CREDENTIAL. 80% OF OUR
PRELIMINARY CREDENTIAL HOLDERS
ARE NOT ENROLLED IN A PROGRAM
AND THE OVERWHELMING MAJORITY
OF THESE NURSES INDICATED THEY
WOULD BE INTERESTED. IN A CLEAR
SCHOOL NURSE SERVICES
CREDENTIAL PROGRAM OFFERED BY
IN ELLIJAY AND VIEW THIS OPTION
AS A REASON TO REMAIN EMPLOYED
AS A SCHOOL NURSE. AB EIGHT ONE
FIVE PERMITS THE COMMISSION ON
TEACHER CREDENTIALING TO
CONSIDER NURSE SERVICES
CREDENTIAL PROGRAMS
APPLICATIONS FROM LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES. THESE
PROGRAMS WOULD BE SUBJECT TO
THE STANDARD APPROVAL CRITERIA
SET FORTH BY THE COMMISSION THE
VERY SAME STANDARDS TO WHICH I
EACH YEAR BASED PROGRAMS ARE
HELD. PROVIDING THIS OPTION
WOULD PERMIT ELLIE IS TO WORK
WITH THE COMMISSION TO CREATE
LOCAL SOLUTIONS TO ADDRESS THE
SCHOOL NURSE RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION CHALLENGES WITHIN OUR
STATE. FOR THESE REASONS THE
LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IS PROUD TO SPONSOR
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT ONE FIVE
AND URGES YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU WILL
NOT GO TO COLLEEN JOHNSON OF
THE CALIFORNIA COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS EDUCATIONAL
SERVICES ASSOCIATION. GOOD
MORNING HERE ARE NOT ALL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
STAFF MY NAME IS COLLEEN
JOHNSON AND I'M THE CHIEF
ADMINISTRATOR HUMAN RESOURCES.
FOR THE SACRAMENTO COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION. I HAVE
SERVED IN THE ROLE OF HR
ADMINISTRATOR FOR THIRTEEN
YEARS AND PRIDE MYSELF. AND
SERVING AS AN EXPERT RECRUITER
FOR EDUCATION CAREERS THAT PAID
SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN THE LIVES
OF OUR STUDENTS. I'M HERE
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENTS
EDUCATIONAL SERVICES
ASSOCIATION OR SUCCESSOR. WHICH
PROVIDES THE ORGANIZATIONAL
MECHANISM FOR THE FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENTS. AS A
DEDICATED MEMBER OF SUCCESS I
HAVE SERVED ON THE PERSONNEL
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES
STEERING COMMITTEE. FOR MANY
YEARS IN THIS CAPACITY I'VE HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE WITH
HR ADMINISTRATORS FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. AND COUNTY OFFICES
OF EDUCATION ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. AND I'M HERE
SURE THAT FOR DECADES ONE OF
THE MOST COMMONLY HARD TO FILL
POSITIONS IN OUR SCHOOLS STATE
WIDE. IS THAT A CREDENTIAL
SCHOOL NURSES AND MORE SO NOW
IN THE FACE OF THE PANDEMIC AND
EFFORTS TO REOPEN OUR SCHOOLS.
I IS NOT IN USE TO HEAR. FROM
MY COUNTERPART THAT THEY HAVE
CREDENTIALS SCHOOL NURSE
CREDENTIAL VACANCY. THEY
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO FIND
ANYONE TO FILL THE POSITIONS
EVEN AFTER INCREASING SALARIES
OFFERING SIGNING BONUSES AND
SON EVEN OFFERING TO PAY FOR
THE CREDENTIAL PROGRAM.
CALIFORNIA'S RELIANCE ON TEST
FOR I. EIGHTY PROGRAMS AND ONLY
ONE IS SERVING NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. IN. TWENTY NINETEEN
TO TWENTY ONLY TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY TWO NEW CLEAR SCHOOL
NURSE CREDENTIALS WERE ISSUED
ACROSS THE ENTIRE STATE. STILL
NURSES WITH THE PRELIMINARY
CREDENTIAL FIND IT DIFFICULT TO
COMPLETE THEIR CAREER THEIR
CLEAR CREDENTIAL WITHIN THE
REQUIRED FIVE YEAR PERIOD. DUE
TO LACK OF PROGRAM AVAILABILITY
WE BELIEVE THAT AB EIGHT
FIFTEEN OPENS UP AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES
IN ALL REGIONS OF OUR STATE TO
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO CHOOSE
TO OFFER A SCHOOL NURSE
CREDENTIAL PROGRAM. WITH THE
GOAL OF SUPPORTING SCHOOL
EMPLOYERS AND RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION OF QUALIFIED SCHOOL
NURSES IN PARTICULAR COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT TRACK RECORD OF
PRODUCING HIGH QUALITY
CREDENTIALING PROGRAMS. FOR
THESE REASONS THE SAYS IT IS
PROUD TO SUPPORT ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHT FIFTEEN THANK YOU AND WE
URGE YOUR YET BUT ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU WELL NOW MOVED TO
OPPOSITION- DR SAMANTHA
BLACKBURN FROM CSU SACRAMENTO-
SCHOOL ISSUES UNDERSCORED LATER
THEIR- DOCTOR BLACKBURN MARK
GOOD MORNING CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES WE CAN PLEASE PROCEED GOOD
MORNING. THANK YOU- I AM-
TESTIFYING IN OPPOSITION. OF
THIS BILL TODAY BECAUSE WE
SIMPLY DON'T NEED THIS PROGRAM.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE- ALL THE
CAPACITY AND ACCESS FOR- SCHOOL
NURSES WITH THEIR PRELIMINARY
CREDENTIAL- YOUR EXISTING FOR
PROGRAMS. FOR THE PAST TWO
YEARS WE'VE BEEN ACCEPTABLE TO
ACCEPT ALL QUALIFIED
APPLICANTS. AND THAT'S YOUR
ATTACK STATE NTS YOU COLLECTION
AS WELL AS FRESNO STATE- AS A
MATTER OF FACT SEVENTEEN OUT OF
THE CURRENT FIFTY STUDENTS WHO
ARE ENROLLED IN FRESNO'S
PROGRAM ARE FROM LA UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT. OUR PROGRAMS
ARE EITHER FULLY ONLINE WELL.
THEY ALL ARE TO THE PANDEMIC.
AND ALL OF THEM ARE- HYBRID
ALLOWING FOR FULL TIME WORKING
SCHOOL NURSES TO EASILY
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM. THE
OTHER THING THE OTHER ISSUE IS
THAT WE NEED SCHOOL OF NURSING
EXPERTISE- COOL NURSES ARE
ENCOURAGED BY THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTE OF MATH MEDICINES
FUTURE OF NURSING REPORT TO
EXCEED A GRADUATE DEGREE TO
SUCCEED AND TO ADVANCE
PROFESSIONALLY. IN FACT 53% OF
TAX STATE CREDENTIAL STUDENTS.
PURSUE THEIR MSN. SO RIGHT NOW
WE HAVE CHAU SIXTY ONE STUDENTS
FROM OUR LAST COHORT OF NINETY
SIX STUDENTS WHO ARE PURSUING
THEIR CREDENTIALS I'M SORRY
THEIR THEIR GRADUATE DEGREE
THEIR MASTER'S DEGREE WHICH IS
OPIONAL BUT WE HAVE OVER HALF
PURSUING THAT GRADUATE DEGREE
BECAUSE SCHOOL NURSES NEEDED
THAT- EXTRA EDUCATION- TO FULLY
ADVANCE. AT SCHOOL NURSES
PLEASE SUMMER HIRES- YEAH. AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A DISTRICT
RUN PROGRAM WILL NOT ADVANCE
THE SCHOOL NURSE PROFESSION.
THANK YOU TO PARTICIPATE IN A
DEBATE THANK YOU WILL NOT LOSE
OUR NEXT WITNESS- DR RACHEL
MCCLANAHAN CSU FORTUNES SCHOOL
NURSE COORDINATOR. HI GOOD
MORNING- MY NAME IS RACHEL
MCCLANAHAN I'M AN ASSOCIATE
PROFESSOR AT CAL STATE
FULLERTON AND LEAD FOR THE
COLLEGE CREDENTIAL PROGRAM
THERE. I THOUGHT THE BLACKBURN
MY SPECIALTY AND MY EXPERTISE
IS IN EDUCATING THEIR SAYS. WE
EDUCATE NURSES WHO WILL WORK IN
THE ICU CARING FOR CULTIVATION.
WE EDUCATE OUR PRACTITIONERS
STOP LOW COST CLINICS THE
STATE. WE EDUCATE NURSES A
DOCTORATE DEGREE IN IMPROVE THE
QUALITY OF THE HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM. AND WE EDUCATE NURSES
WHO WANT TO EARN A CREDENTIAL
AND WORK IN SCHOOL. WE THE
QUALITY OF EDUCATION THAT ALL
OF THESE NOTHING SPECIAL TO YOU
ARE. WE HAVE THE ABILITIES
INFRASTRUCTURE RESOURCES
EXPERIENCE EXPERTISE TO EDUCATE
THEM THAT. WE HAVE WELL
ESTABLISHED STIMULATION LAB AND
HIGHLY EDUCATED AND EXPERIENCED
FACULTY. IT IS WHAT WE DO EVERY
DAY AND WE DO IT WELL. AS YOU
CAN IMAGINE WE ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE QUALITY OF
INSTRUCTION STUDENTS WOULD
RECEIVE THEIR AN ALLEY A NURSE
CREDENTIAL PROGRAM BECAUSE WELL
L. YOU CAN EXPERIENCE USING
TEACHERS AND- EDUCATING NURSES
IS NOT THE SAME THING. A DOCTOR
BLACKBURN. GIVEN THE COMPLEXITY
OF THE CARE REQUIRED BY
CHILDREN ATTENDING SCHOOL. AND
THE STANDARD OF CARE THAT
NURSES PROVIDE. EDUCATION
SECRETARY GOES BEYOND THE
TRADITIONAL HONORED TEACHING
CREDENTIAL PROGRAM. WE THINK
THAT THERE ARE BETTER WAYS TO
APPROACH THAT THAT WILL ALLOW
FOR THE PRESERVATION OF HIGH
STANDARDS FOR NURSING EDUCATION
THAT ARE ALREADY ESTABLISHED IN
OUR STATE. RATHER THAN BUILDING
SOMETHING FROM THE GROUND UP
STARTING FROM SCRATCH
RECREATING THE WHEEL AND
DUPLICATING SERVICES ALREADY
INSTITUTED. WE PROPOSE THAT
THERE IS A BETTER APPROACH ONE
THAT WOULD SUPPORT EVERYONE
INVOLVED THE CLERK DIDN'T
RETALIATES AND THE INSTITUTION
OF NOTHING ITSELF. WE BELIEVE
THAT THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
PARTNERSHIP AGREEMENT OF SOME
KIND WHETHER THEY BE
SCHOLARSHIPS FOR STUDENTS A
FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM OR SOME
OTHER ARRANGEMENT THAT WOULD
WORK FOR BOTH ELEAZAR AND
UNIVERSITIES TO ALLOW FOR AND
ENSURE THAT FULLER CREDENTIALS
DIDN'T CONTINUE TO RECEIVE.
DEMONSTRATED HIGH QUALITY
EDUCATION THAT GIVES THEM
UNIVERSITY CREDIT AND AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR FUTURE
ADVANCEMENT. WITH SUCH A HUGE
OUTLAY TIME AND FINANCE
INDEFINITE TO ESTABLISH A NEW
PROGRAM AND THE SON RUN KNOWN
LIKE. HOW MANY NURSES ACTUALLY
ATTEND. AN ALTERNATIVE BILL
ALTERNATIVE TO THE FILL IN THE
FORM A PARTNERSHIP CAN REDUCE
THE LIABILITY FOR ILLEGAL
UTILIZING AND LEVERAGING OUR
THIRTY CAN YOU DOCTOR AND
EXPERTISE I'M ALMOST DONE. I
THINK YOU'RE A CUBICLE HELLO
PEOPLE AND PROVIDE NOW ATTACK.
TO THE WE HEARD SUPPORT A
SUPPORT OPPOSITION NUMBERING
ABOUT TO THE COMMITTEE. DO WE
HAVE A MOTION. MISTER MOVES-
THIS CALL SHOWS YOU WANT TO
SECOND GUESS THIS HAS BEEN
MOVED IN SECOND MCCARTY IT WAS
TO COME JUST A QUESTION IF MADE
YOU COULD RESPOND TO THE
OPPOSITION OUTLINED THEIR TO
HELP EXPLAIN SITUATION FOR US
UP HERE SURE THANK YOU MISTER
MCCARTY IS THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE ELEAZAR TO MEET THE
SAME REQUIREMENTS AND QUALITY
STANDARDS AS EXISTING NURSE
CREDENTIALING PROGRAMS- L. HELP
ALLEVIATE OF THE BACKLOG THAT
YOU KNOW CANDIDATES FACE IN IN
TRYING TO GET INTO THE EXISTING
PROGRAMS. OF THE COME THE CTC
WILL HAVE TO OF APPROVED EACH
OF THESE PROGRAMS AND SO THEY
WILL USE THE SAME STANDARDS AS
THEY DO ACROSS THE STATE SO.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. SEEING THE FURTHER
CON FOR THE COMMITTEE WE DO
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND- WE
CAN GO TO THE PUBLIC AFTER TEN
MINUTES. THANK YOU TO STATE
YOUR OPINION- AP EIGHT ONE FIVE
PRESS ONE OF THEM ZERO AGAIN
THAT'S ONE OF THEM ZERO. WE'LL
GO TO LINE ONE OF. SEVEN ONE
HUNDRED SEVEN I'M SORRY WILL
MOVE TO ONE OH EIGHT. ALSO NOT
AVAILABLE. WELL I AM THIRTY
FOUR THREE FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES MEDIA REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL NURSES
ORGANIZATION- WE CONCUR WITH
THE COMMENTS ABOUT COLLEAGUES
WE ARE OPPOSED TO NEXT ONE NO
VOTE ON AB. EIGHT FIFTEEN. WHAT
A LINE SEVENTY TWO SEVEN TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIVE THIS IS
JASON CHILD ARTICOLI OF THE
INDIVIDUAL AT THE HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS FROM SAN FRANCISCO- IN
STRONG SUPPORT. WE'LL GO NEXT
TO LINE EIGHTY TWO EIGHTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FOR PASSING
WITH THE ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE TOP. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AT THIS TIME NO
FURTHER LINE DURING Q. THANK
YOU WE DO A MOTION AND A SECOND
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. OF PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL HI
FOR DONALD HI KILEY KILEY I'D
BENNETT. DALI DALI HI LEAVE
MCCARTY. MCCARTY HI QUICK SILVA.
QUICKSILVER HI IT HAS FIVE
BUTTONS BILLS FOR A VOTE IT IS
OUT. THANK THEM THANK YOU. A
GOOD JOB I WILL NOW MOVE TO MR
MEDINA. OKAY MISS READY TO AB
THREE EIGHTY EIGHT THAT'S FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE. BY- TWELVE.
GOOD MORNING MR MEMBES I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT A. B. THREE
EIGHTY EIGHT A MEASURE THAT
WILL ENSURE THAT NON
ADMINISTRATIVE EDUCATION
EMPLOYEES SERVING IN POSITIONS
REQUIRING CERTIFICATION WILL
BECOME PERMANENT EMPLOYEES
FOLLOWING A PROBATIONARY.
PERIOD TODAY EXPERIENCED
EDUCATORS IN SMALLER SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE BEING DISMISSED
AND TERMINATED FOR ARBITRARY
REASONS WITHOUT WARNING. UNDER
CURRENT LAW ONLY CERTIFICATED
EMPLOYEES IN TEACHING POSITION
AT COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION
WITH THE AVERAGE DAILY
ATTENDANCE OF MORE THAN TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY PUPILS CAN
ACHIEVE PERMANENT STATUS AFTER
PROBATIONARY PERIOD. THIS MEANS
THAT CERTIFIED CERTIFICATED
EMPLOYEES IN NON TEACHING
POSITIONS DO NOT HAVE THE RIGHT
TO ATTAIN PERMANENT STATUS.
THIS POLICY AFFECTS GROUPS OF
CERTIFICATED EMPLOYEES SUCH AS
SCHOOL NURSES ENGLISH LANGUAGE
AT EDUCATORS. FOSTER YOUTH
COUNSELORS AND SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHERS WITH
SEVERELY DISABLED STUDENTS
AMONG OTHERS. IN THE CASE OF A
DISMISSAL A PERMANENT EMPLOYEE
STATUS WOULD ALLOW EMPLOYEES TO
REQUEST A HEARING BEFORE THE
COMMISSION ON PROFESSIONAL
COMPETENCE TO DECIDE WHETHER
THE DISMISSAL WAS APPROPRIATE.
FURTHER A PERMANENT EMPLOYEE
HAS THE RIGHT TO REQUEST A
HEARING. DURING A REDUCTION IN
FORCE. UNFORTUNATELY SEVERAL
CLASSES OF EMPLOYEES HAVE BEEN
INAPPROPRIATE BE DENIED
PERMANENT STATUS BASED ON THE
NEED TO CREATE FISCAL SOLVENCY.
OR ANTICIPATION THAT NEEDS FOR
SERVICES IN THE FUTURE PER IN
SECURE. THIS LACK OF PERMANENT
STATUS HAS ALSO LED TO
DISCRIMINATION RETALIATION AND
FAVORITISM WITHIN OUR SMALLER
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. THIS BILL
WILL REMEDY THE SITUATION
TREATING ALL CERTIFICATED
EDUCATION EMPLOYEES WITH
DIGNITY RESPECT AND
PROFESSIONALISM THAT THEY
DESERVE. MY WITNESSES TODAY OUR
TO EDUCATORS FROM THE LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
COULD TREES MOVE A ROO AND
ELIZABETH KIRCHER. YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN READY. COUNTRIES.
THREE THE MORNING. YES MY NAME
IS PATRICE OUTLOOK THE ROOM AND
I'M INSTRUCTORS AT WEST VALLEY
OCCUPATIONAL CENTER WHERE I
KEEP PHYSICAL THERAPY AND
SPORTS THEIR PIECE AND I
HAPPENED TO THOUSAND NINE. I
BELIEVE I WAS THE FIRST
INSTRUCTOR TO TEACH ME ABOUT
THESE PROGRAMS. WITHIN THE LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
ADOPTED VISION. OVER THE YEARS
I'VE HAD. THE PLEASURE OF
NURTURING AND EXPANDING
PROGRAMS TO OTHER CAMPUSES
WITHIN OUR DIVISION. I AM VERY
PASSIONATE ABOUT THE WORK THAT
I DO. BECAUSE WE TRAIN
UNDERSERVED STUDENTS FOR
CAREERS IN THE HEALTHCARE
INDUSTRY. WHICH IS SIMPLY HELP
TO SUPPORT THE PIPELINE. FOR
CALIFORNIA WORKERS. MICHAEL IS
A TEACHER. RIGHT NOW HELP
FUNDERS OF STUDENTS OF
MARGINALIZED GROUPS AND ENGLISH
LEARNERS TO GET JOBS THAT HELP
TO PROVIDE FOR THE FAMILY. MANY
OF MY STUDENTS. HAVE ALSO
CONTINUED ON TO HIGHER
EDUCATION. THAT IS WHY IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE. WHEN BLOCK.
DISTRICT ALL PROGRAMS ON THE
CHOPPING BLOCK LIKE MANY OF THE
TEACHERS. I ADVOCATED I WROTEFOR MEMBERS ABOUT OUR STUDENTS
AND OUR PROGRAMS AND WHAT
THEY'RE DOING FOR OUR
COMMUNITY. I ALSO WROTE A
LETTER TO THE WHITE HOUSE ABOUT
ONE OF MY STUDENTS. FOR THE
STATE HOME MOM WAS ABLE TO GET
A CERTIFICATE AND GET A JOB AT
A HOSPITAL IN THE PHYSICAL
THERAPY DEPARTMENT. WHICH
HELPED THE SINGLE FAMILY. THAT
LETTER. IN BEING TO MEET PRESS
DONALD. FOR LUNCH AND TO
FOURTEEN. AND ALSO I INTRODUCED
HIM TO FORGET THE JUNCKER
TRAINING AT LAW FAIRS THE
TECHNICAL TRADE COLLEGE. IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN I WAS INVITED
BACK TO HIM AGAIN THE OVAL
OFFICE. AND I WAS THE GUEST OF
THE FIRST LADY OF THE STATE OF
THE UNION MICHELLE OBAMA AS THE
CREW TRAINING EDUCATOR. BE THE
BEST BROUGHT A LOT OF PRIDE AND
JOY TO MY SCHOOL AND THE
DISTRICT. AS A RESULT I
RECEIVED A LETTER RECREATION
FOR THE SUPERINTENDENT AT THE
TIME FROM MORE CRISTINA. I
PRINCIPLE ALSO RECOGNIZE ME IT
CURRENTLY TO GET MY MASTER'S
DEGREE IN EDUCATIONAL
LEADERSHIP WHICH I DID. EVEN
WITH MY MASTER'S DEGREE AND ALL
THE ACTUALLY IT IS NOT CHANGED
MY STATUS. I STILL DO NOT HAVE
ANY JOB SECURITY HOURS ARE
COSTLY CUT FLUCTUATING FROM
TWENTY THIRTY SUMMARIZING EVEN
AT LOW. I WANT TO CONTINUE TO
SERVE MY STUDENTS IN THE
COMMUNITY IN ORDER TO DO THIS I
NEED PERMANENT STATUS. THESE
PROGRAMS ARE INVALUABLE TO OUR
COMMUNITY AS WE ARE KEEPING
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU FOR THE
MEET BUT WHEN JOB AND TO THE
ECONOMY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WILL NOW MOVE TO
ELIZABETH CATCHING. ELIZABETH
YOU MAY PROCEED ONE. THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS THE KITCHEN AND I
TEACH PRESS A SECOND LANGUAGE
FOR EVENTS ADULT I HAVE BEEN
TEACHING PIANO CHAU. NINETEEN
NINETY. IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE
AND AGAIN IT'S THOUSAND. I WAS
LAID OFF NOT BE MY PASSPORT.
BUT BECAUSE OF BUDGET THAT HOW
MANY FOUND AND I WAS VERY HIGH.
I'M NOT ONE OF ICE AND IT'S ALL
SET YOU ARE PUT. TEMPORARY
REGARDLESS OF OUR PERFORMANCE
WE HAVE NO PATH TO PERMANENT
STATUS WE ARE TREATED
DIFFERENTLY FROM OTHER EACHRS
ON THE STATE OR THE COUNTRY.
WHY DO WE PUT UP WITH THAT.
MANY OF US HAVE MASTERS DEGREES
AND WE COULD TEACH COMMUNITY
COLLEGE BUT WE DO IT BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE IN OUR STUDENTS AND WE
BELIEVE IN WHAT WE HAVE TO
OFFER THEM. IN NOVEMBER TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN A YOUNG MAN
IN THE WHEELCHAIR CAME INTO MY
LEVEL FIVE ESL CLASS HE HAD
ALMOST BEEN KILLED IN A
TERRIBLE MOTORCYCLE ACCIDENT. I
THINK HE INVOLVED IN COMPUTER
CLASS AT THE SAME TIME THE GSL
HE PASSED LEVEL FIVE DIMENSION
UP IN MY CLASSROOM LEVEL SIX.
HE TOLD ME HE WAS TAKING THE
NEXT LEVEL COMPUTER CLASS AND
LEARNING PROGRAMS. I AM SO
PROUD OF THE VISION MAN I FEEL
HONORED TO BE HIS TEACHER I'M
ALSO PROUD OF OUR PROGRAMS THAT
PROVIDE ENGLISH AND AFFORDABLE
JOB TRAINING. WHERE ELSE IS THE
JOHN MEMBERS GILLS TO BECOME
INDEPENDENT. AND SUPPORT
THEMSELVES. MANY OF A FAIR
TRIAL AND WATCH THE GROUND CRAP
GAP BETWEEN THE VERY RICH AND
THE POOR MISTER. AND WE STILL
HELPLESS TO DO ANYTHING A IT.
AND I DON'T THINK YOU CAN. WE
ARE DOING SOMETHING IT. WE'RE
PROVIDING COST. FOR STUDENTS TO
THEIR LIFE AND WORKS THERE OUT
POP. I BELIEVE IN MY STUDENTS
AND I BELIEVE IN OUR PROGRAM.
THE ONLY PROBLEM IS THAT MY
EMPLOYER DOES NOT BELIEVE IN
ME. DOES NOT VALUE ME FORGIVE
ME JOB SECURITY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WILL NOW OVER YOUR
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MISTER ALI
OF DO HAVE A MOTION. MR
MCCARTY. MR KILEY SECONDS I'M
SORRY I'M FINE ARE YOU SECOND
NO I'M NOT OKAY I MUST MISS
WORK SO SECOND OKAY I IS STILL
HAVE A QUESTION FOR HIM IS A
FIRST. GOOD MORNING APART SO AS
YOU KNOW I REPRESENT A VERY
RULE DISTRICT WITH AND I'VE
HEARD FROM SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS
ACROSS MY DISTRICT AS WELL AS
SMALL SCHOOLS AND THEY HAVE A
LOT OF CONCERNS ABOUT THIS
BILL- WE'RE ACTUALLY AND I'VE
SERVED ON SCHOOL WORK MYSELF SO
IN OUR AREA IT'S ACTUALLY VERY
HARD TO FILL THESE POSITIONS
WITH QUALIFIED INDIVIDUALS. SO
I'M WONDERING THERE'S A LOT OF
OPPOSITION FROM THE SMALL
SCHOOLS HAVE YOU BEEN WORKING
WITH THEM ON POSSIBLE
AMENDMENTS OR ARE YOU
CONVERSATIONS WHAT'S THE STATUS.
YES ACTUALLY- ASSEMBLY WOMAN I
DID ALSO MET WITH THE
REPRESENTATIVES OF SMALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS- RIGHT YOU KNOW
APPRECIATE THAT THEIR CONCERNS.
ARE SO WE HAVE BEEN IN
CONVERSATION- I ALSO WAS A
SCHOOL BOARD- NOT NOT OF A
SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICT- AND I
DID HEAR FROM THEM THAT. AND
SOME OF THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
IT'S ONLY THE SUPERINTENDENT
WHO MAY HAVE- TENURE AND VERY
VERY SMALL- SUPERINTENDENT
MIGHT BE- SUPERINTENDENT AND
TEACHER SO I DO UNDERSTAND-
THOSE CONCERNS AND WE ARE IN
CONVERSATION- WILL CONTINUE
I'LL CONTINUE TO BE IN
CONVERSATION WITH THEM- BUT- I
VERY MUCH. SYMPATHIZED WITH THE
TEACHERS LIKE THE TEACHER THAT
WE HEARD FROM WHO WHO CAN BE
TWENTY YEARS AT THEIR JOB AND
NEVER GET PERMANENT STATUS. SO-
I THINK THIS BILL TRIES TO-
RECTIFY THAT AND AT THE SAME
TIME I THINK WE CAN TRY TO WORK
WITH THE SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
MORRELL I'D LIKE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE TO WORK
ON SOME AMENDMENTS THAT COULD
POSSIBLY. REMINI THEIR- A HUGE
CONCERNS. FOR MORE FLEXIBILITY
NOT LESS RIGHT NOW DURING OUR
SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN OPEN WHICH IS
NOT BEEN THE CASE FOR MOST OF
THE STATE SO IT'S BEEN REALLY
CHALLENGING TO FILL THOSE
POSITIONS BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY
PEOPLE ARE CONCERNED TO COME TO
WORK YOU KNOW DURING CALVET SO
I BY TECH CONTENT CONVERSATION
IF I COULD WITH YOU. WILL DO
HAPPY TO STAY IN CONVERSATION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND I
THINK I MADE A MISTAKE HERE
BECAUSE MACHITO WILL MIXED UP
BUT- I HAVE MATTHEW DUSTIN
POSSIBLY ON THE PHONE. IN
OPPOSITION. YES GOOD MORNING.
YES YOU MAY PROCEED SORRY I
APOLOGIZE MY FAULT. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR VICE CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS MATTHEW DUSTIN I'M THE
SUPERINTENDENT PRINTABLE AND
MIDDLE SCHOOL SCIENCE TEACHER
AT MONTAGUE ELEMENTARY SCHOOL.
WHERE CATER EIGHT SCHOOL AND
SISKIYOU COUNTY ABOUT TWENTY
MILES FROM THE OREGON BORDER
OUR ENROLLMENT AND THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY SCHOOL YEAR WAS
ONE HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE STUDENTS
THIS YEAR WE ARE CURRENTLY
SERVING ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY ONE
STUDENTS THERE IN PERSON. AND
DISTANCE LEARNING. THERE IS NO
QUESTION THAT OUR TEACHERS ARE
THE BACKBONE OF OUR SCHOOL
COMMUNITY AND WE APPRECIATE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MEDINA AFTER
TO PROVIDE THESE INSTRUCTORS
WITH SOME ADDITIONAL THAT THAT
STABILITY. HOWEVER IN DISTRICTS
LIKE MINE FLEXIBILITY IN TERMS
OF WORKFORCE DECISIONS ARE
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL. SMALL
DISTRICT ADMINISTRATOR FOR MANY
SMALL DISTRICT ADMINISTRATORS
THE LINE BETWEEN MANAGEMENT AND
LABOR IS BLURRED.AS WE PUT ALL
THE ROLE OF THE BOTH
ADMINISTRATOR AND CLASSROOM
TEACHER EACH DAY TO REMAIN
FISCALLY SOLVENT. EVEN QUITE
POPULATIONS IN OUR ENROLLMENT
MEAN THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
NEEDING OR NOT NEEDING-
SECONDARY TEACHERS IN
PARTICULAR BUT ALSO SECOND
CLASSROOM- INSTRUCTORS AT EACH
GRADE LEVEL. I FOR EXAMPLE
BETWEEN THE TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN AND SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN SCHOOL YEAR OUR
ENROLLMENT DROPPED FROM
1-007-521-0050 FOUR STUDENT. AT
THE 12% DROP IN ONE SCHOOL YEAR
THAT WOULD BE THE EQUIVALENT OF
LONG BEACH UNIFIED LOSING
NEARLY NINE THOUSAND STUDENTS
BETWEEN ACADEMIC YEARS. AT THAT
TIME TO TEACHERS WERE RELEASED
AS WELL THE PART TIME
ADMINISTRATOR. AND WE'RE
BEGINNING TO SEE IN THE NEWS
PARENTS HAVE RELOCATED TO
DISTRICTS WHERE SCHOOLS WERE
OPENED. BY AND LARGE THE
SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN A SMALL RURAL
DISTRICTS. HOWEVER THERE'S NO
WAY TO KNOW IF THESE THREE
LOCATIONS WILL BE PERMANENT
PART STUDENTS WILL MOVE AGAIN
AFTER THE PANDEMIC AND THE
SCHOOLS ARE OPEN ACROSS THE
STATE. SCHOOLS ARE NOT
BUSINESSES WE DO NOT HAVE THE
ABILITY TO SET PRICES. WE
OPERATE ON BUDGETS THAT ARE
TIED DIRECTLY TO ENROLLMENT OR
IN THE CASE OF THE CURRENT YEAR
A BUDGET WHICH FOR MY SCHOOL IS
LOCKED AT ONLY 90% OF OUR
CURRENT ENROLLMENT AFTER EIGHTY
A WAS FROZEN IN TWENTY TWENTY.
ALLOWING US TO RE CAPTURE ONLY
A SMALL AMOUNT OF OUR GROWTH
FUNDING UNDER SB EIGHT TWENTY.
TO MAKE A PERMANENT POLICY
CHANGE LIKE THIS ESPECIALLY
RIGHT NOW WITH THE GROUP GROUND
IS STILL MOVING BENEATH THAT'S
WITH LOCK DISTRICTS INTO A
SITUATION. THAT COULD BE A
VIABLE IN THE FUTURE IF WE WORK
HARD TO MAINTAIN. A TEACHING
FORCE THAT EXCEEDS STUDENT NEED.
FOR A- EIGHT. FIVE THREE EIGHTY
EIGHT TO BECOME LAW THE SENSE
OF SECURITY OR TEACHERS MIGHT
ENJOY WOULD UNFORTUNATELY BE
FALL. WE CANNOT PREDICT WHAT
ENROLLMENT WILL LOOK LIKE YEARS
INTO THE FUTURE AND
FLUCTUATIONS THAT A LARGER
DISTRICT WOULD CONSIDER. THANK
YOU WILL NOW MOVE ON TO OTHER
LYNCH. NEED TO REMAIN FLEXIBLE
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN O'DONNELL IN THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS I HAVE TWENTY
NINE YEARS OF EXPERIENCE IN
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION MY
NAME'S ALYSSA LYNCH AND I'M THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF METROPOLITAN
EDUCATION DISTRICT AND R. O. P.
SERVING TWELVE HUNDRED STUDENTS
AND SILICON VALLEY. I'M NOT
SURE WHERE WE PREPARE STUDENTS
FOR COLLEGE AND CAREERS IN
SECTORS SUCH AS MEDICAL
ASSISTING FIRE SCIENCE AND
ENGINEERING. AB THREE EIGHT
EIGHT WOULD REQUIRE AS YOU
EXTEND PERMANENT STATUS TO RCP
TEACHERS WHICH WOULD UPEND THE
CTP PROGRAMS THAT WE ARE ABLE
TO OFFER OUR STUDENTS. ARE
PROGRAMS ARE SUCCESSFUL BECAUSE
OF THE INNOVATIVE AND RELEVANT
PATHWAYS WE TEACH CURRENT
STATUTE ABOARD ARE PROGRAMS
FLEXIBILITY TO ADAPT YOU ARE
GDP. AND ALWAYS THAT ALLOWS
THEM TO STAY CURRENT. TO THE
pCHANGES AFFECT WHAT COURSES WE
OFFER OR NOT OFFER IF ON LOCAL
WORKING NEEDS. AS AN EXAMPLE I
NAY HAVE EXCEEDED E. TEACHER
WITH A CREDIT IN HEALTH SCIENCE.
AND MADDOX WHO TEACHES MEDICAL.
IT DOES NOT BUT THAT DOES NOT
MEAN THAT THEY CAN TEACH
DENTISTRY. ANOTHER EXAMPLE I
HAVE A LEGAL CAREERS TEACHER
BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT HE
OR SHE COULD TEACH OF FIRE
SCIENCE CLASS. IF YOU HAVE A
TEACHER WITH A CREDENTIAL THAT
THEY'RE NOT QUALIFIED TO TEACH
THAT COULD BE A BIG MISTAKE ALL
CTE TEACHERS HAVE VASTLY
DIFFERENT WORK EXPERIENCE AND
SKILLS. UNDER THIS BILL AB
THREE EIGHT EIGHT WOULD REQUIRE
A STORAGE WENT RETAIN CTE
TEACHERS IN INDUSTRIES. THAT
MAY NOT HAVE A LABOR MARKET I
COULD BE FORCED TO HAVE TO
LEGAL CAREER TEACHERS WHEN I
NEED TO FIRE FINE FEATURES.
EIGHTEEN PROGRAMS OFFERED ARE
ARE BASED ON STUDENT
ENROLLMENT. AB THREE EIGHT
EIGHT WHAT ALSO FORCED ME TO
OFFER PROGRAMS THAT I DO NOT
HAVE STUDENTS ENROLLED IN. IN
CLOSING IT'S NOT A HYPER
HYPERBOLE TO SAY THAT IF EIGHTY
THREE EIGHT EIGHT MOVES FORWARD
AS INTRODUCED WOULD LIKELY MEAN
THE END OF ROC. IN A MATTER OF
JUST YEARS BECAUSE IT WOULD
REMOVE OUR ABILITY TO PROPERLY
RESPOND TO THE NEEDS OF THE
LABOR MARKET IN INDUSTRY WHICH
IS THE BEAUTY OF CTE PROGRAMS.
I URGE YOU TO VOTE NOW ON AB.
THREE EIGHT EIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE WILL NOT BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE WE HAD
COMMENTS FURTHER. EARLIER WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE THOSE
COMMENTS- MISTER KILEY. I THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I- I'M GONNA
HAVE TO OPPOSE THIS BILL TODAY
AND I'LL AFTER THE COMMENTS OF
THE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION AS
WELL AS ASSEMBLY WOMAN. AT
DALLY YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA-
ALREADY INTERFERES MORE WITH
THE PERSONNEL DECISIONS OF
SCHOOL LEADERS ALIKE- MR DUSTIN
WHO JUST HEARD FROM AL OR
INTERFERES AS MUCH AS ANY OTHER
STATE I MEAN WE'RE ONE OF ONLY.
FIVE STATES IN THE COUNTRY THAT
HAS A PROBATIONARY PERIOD OF
LESS THAN THREE YEARS YOU'D
THINK THAT SINCE WE'RE SUCH A
LARGE STATE WE WOULD. BE LESS
CENTRALIZED IN FACT WERE MORE
CENTRALIZED IN TERMS OF THE
STATE INTERFERING WITH THE
PERSONNEL DECISIONS. OF SCHOOL
LEADERS AND SO- THIS BILL YOU
KNOW ELIMINATES SORT OF A
MODICUM OF FLEXIBILITY THAT IS
RESERVED. FOR SMALLER DISTRICTS
I THINK THAT'S EXACTLY THE
OPPOSITE OF WHAT WE NEED WHAT
I'D LIKE TO SEE. IS- IS TENURE
REFORM THAT- PUTS US MORE IN
LINE WITH THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY AND- THAT'S THE
OVERWHELMING PREFERENCE OF
TEACHERS AND PACKED- IT SURVEYS
SHOW. WE HAVE HAD EFFORTS OF
THE AND OUT OF THIS LEGISLATURE
OF COURSE MY FIRST YEAR IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. TO SPEAK THE
BILL MISTER KILEY ENDEAVOR FOR
THE RECORD CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
TEACHERS OCCASIONAL TEACHERS DO
NOT. GET TENURE YOU WILL NOT
FIND THAT WORD. THANKS FOR THAT
AND I CAN FINISH MY IN ACTIONS
EXCEPT. THAT'S RECALL
PROFESSORS OKAY NEGATIVES MUST
PLEASE. SO I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
THINGS MOVE IN THE OTHER
DIRECTION WE HAVE SEEN. EFFORT
THAT IN THE PAST THAT HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL IN THIS COMMITTEE
BUT I THINK IT'S A- SAD
COMMENTARY ON THE DIRECTION
THAT WE'RE MOVING. AT A THAT
WE'VE MOVED THAT NOW NOT ONLY.
ARE THOSE PROPOSALS NO LONGER
HERE OR VIABLE. BUT WE'RE
ACTUALLY MAKING THINGS EVEN
WORSE SO I WOULD- YOU KNOW
ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONSIDER THAT
AS THIS BILL MOVES MOVES ALONG.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER COMMENT
MISS CORK SILVA. TO MY ESTEEMED
COLLEAGUE I KNOW WE HAVE SPENT
MANY HOURS TALKING ABOUT
EDUCATION AND WE ARE BOTH HUGE
PUBLIC EDUCATION ADVOCATES BOTH
SERVING AS TEACHERS OURSELVES I
DIDN'T MEET WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL BOARDS IN
THEY DID- EXPRESS THEIR CONCERN
NOW THEIR CONCERN IS AND NOT
WHAT I'VE HEARD FROM MY OTHER
COLLEAGUES THEIR CONCERN WAS
THEIR FEAR OF. HAVING TO
NOTICE- AND EMPLOYEES BY MARCH
FIFTEENTH AND HOW MUCH THAT
REALLY CAN BE VERY UPSETTING AS
MANY TIMES THOSE EMPLOYEES ARE
IN FACT THEN BROUGHT BACK BUT
BECAUSE OF OUR DEADLINES FOR
BUDGET. THAT THAT NOT ONLY
HAPPENS WITH CLASSIFIED BUT
CERTIFIED AND SOMETIMES THE
CONCERN OF LOSING EMPLOYEES
THAT MAY GO ELSEWHERE BECAUSE
THEY'VE BEEN GIVEN SO I WOULD
JUST ASK AND I AM I DID GIVE A
SECOND AND I AM SUPPORTING THIS
BILL THAT YOU CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE OPPOSITION. AS OF. THE
OPPOSITION STATEMENTS RIGHT NOW
PARTICULARLY UNDER THE C. T. E.
ARE OF CONCERN WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE GIVE PEOPLE-
PERMANENT STATUS BUT WE ALSO
DON'T LIMIT OUR OPPORTUNITIES
TO HAVE PEOPLE EMPLOYED IN THE
MOST UP TO DATE KERR
PROFESSIONS- CTAS AN EXAMPLE OF
THAT PHOTOGRAPHY MIGHT HAVE
BEEN. SOMETHING WE WERE
TEACHING OVER THE LAST FEW
DECADES AND NOW WE MIGHT NEED
TO BE TEACHING OF THE
PROGRAMMING AND- CANNOT
TEACHER. TEACH BOTH A AS WAS
NOTED SO AGAIN I WILL SUPPORT
IT TODAY BUT WOULD. ENCOURAGE
YOU TO CONTINUE TO SPEAK TO THE
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU FOR THE
COMMENT FROM THE MANY SENIOR
FURTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE WILL GO TO THE PHONES
FOR NO MORE THAN TEN MINUTES.
IF YOU HAVE A COMMENT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. WE'LL GO
TO THE LINE OF WORK EIGHTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THEIR CLIENT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT EDUCATIONAL
SERVICES ASSOCIATION AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. TO
EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY. WE'LL GO
TO LINE OF ONE SEVENTEEN. YES
HELLO THREE FIVE BEHALF THE
COMPANY SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN RESPECT FOR
THIS THANK YOU. WE'LL GO TO
LINE. ONE TWENTY THREE. THANK
YOU RICHARD MEMBERS TRUSTED
BROWN LOOKS HERE UNION OF
EDUCATOR CLASS BY PROFESSIONALS
WITH STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER
EIGHTY SEVEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS JEFF PARKER
REPRESENTING THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS IN OPPOSITION. WE'LL GO
TO LINE ONE TWENTY FOUR. DAVID
GOOD ROW ON BEHALF OF THE SMALL
MANUFACTURERS INSTITUTE WE
SUPPORT AB THREE EIGHTY EIGHT
BECAUSE SOME BUSINESS GRADE
EMPLOYS A SIMILAR TO GREAT
TEACHERS YOU HAVE TO PAY THEM
FAIRLY TO KEEP THEM. LAST YEAR
WE SURVEYED ALMOST THREE
HUNDRED INDUSTRIAL THANK YOU
HOPE THANK YOU CHEERS. THANK
YOU. WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE OH
SIX. GOOD MORNING CHRISTINA
MARCELLUS ON BEHALF OF THE
SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION OPPOSITION. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE ELEVEN.
GOOD MORNING MY MONEY I CAN OUT
THERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STP JPA COLLECTION
IN STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE EIGHTY
EIGHT. HELLO MY NAME IS ERICA
THE BELLA VITA AN ADULT
EDUCATOR AND I'M IN SUPPORT.
WE'LL GO TO LINE. ONE TEN. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
BILL LUCY AT THE MAD BOYS IN
OPPOSITION. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE NUMBER EIGHTY TWO. LARA
PATENT BUT THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS AND STRONG
OPPOSITION. WE'LL GO TO LINE.
SEVENTY THREE. YES GOOD MORNING
MAIN LONG TERM ST LOUIS
EDUCATOR UCLA IN STRONG FAVOR
FOR THIS BILL. THANK. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE THIRTEEN.
GOOD MORNING PATRICIA RUCKER
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
WHERE THE COLD SPONSORED THE
BILL WHAT WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
ONE TWENTY. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ANDREA BALL
AND A HALF OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND THE
CENTRAL VALLEY EDUCATION
COALITION IN OPPOSITION. WE'LL
GO TO LINE ONE SIXTEEN. GOOD
MORNING ELIZABETH ASKED ABOUT
WHAT THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF SCHOOL BUSINESS OFFICIALS
AND OPPOSITION THANK YOU. WE'LL
GO TO LINE NUMBER SIXTY SEVEN.
MORNING LOW UNITED TEACHERS OF
LOS ANGELES AND STRONG SUPPORT.
WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER SEVENTY
FOUR. MATTHEW COGAN DIRECTOR OF
ADULT EDUCATION FOR UNITED
TEACHERS LOS ANGELES. IN STRONG
SUPPORT BECAUSE THIS BILL AND
ALL PART OF EXISTING LAW LIMITS
THE FLEXIBILITY TO CHOOSE THE
HORSES OR PROGRAM CHOICES OF
ADMINISTRATORS THANK. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER ONE
NINETEEN. BOB I. NEXT WE'LL GO
TO LINE NUMBER SIXTY FIVE. YES
MY NAME IS KEVIN JORDAN THE
ARMENIAN ADULT EDUCATOR UNITED
TEACHERS- LOS ANGELES IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY
EIGHT THANK YOU. WE'LL GO TO
LINE NUMBER ONE FIFTEEN. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
FINANCIALLY READ ON BEHALF OF
CARE AT EACH DESTINATION ALEX
CAREER AND COLLEGE READINESS
ORGANIZATION IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER ONE TWENTY SEVEN. ONE
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
OKAY WE'LL MOVE ON WE'LL GO TO
LINE NUMBER TWENTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. DIANA A YOUNG ALL
REPRESENTS EIGHTEEN POATE THE
COALITION ON ADULT BASIC
EDUCATION AT THE FELLOW
STRONGLY SUPPORT. WE'LL GO TO
LINE NUMBER. ONE TWENTY SIX.
NAME MICHAEL TURNER- RESIDENT
UTILITY LOS ANGELES AND I'M
STRONG SUPPORT AB. THREE EIGHTY
EIGHT. THAT THIS TIME THERE ARE
NO FURTHER. THANK YOU- WITH
THAT- WE HAVE DONE A SECURE TO
HAVE TO EMOTIONAL YES WE DO
OKAY BALDUR'S ARE WITHOUT A YOU
MAY CLOSE MISTER MEDINA THANK
YOU AND I WOULD SAY TO THE
COLLEAGUES WHO BROUGHT UP- THE
OPPOSITION. BY THAT I CONTINUE
TO KEEP BUT SPEAKING WITH THEM.
ADDRESSING THEIR CONCERNS- BUT
AS A AS A TEACHER FOR THIRTY
FOUR YEARS. I KNOW FIRST HAND
THE IMPORTANCE OF NOT HAVING
ARBITRARY DECISIONS MADE ON
TERMINATION OF TEACHERS AND THE
PRECARIOUS POSITION THAT THESE
TEACHERS ARE IN. YEAR AFTER
YEAR NOT HAVING PERMANENT
STATUS BUT BEING TEMPORARY- AND
THAT ALL TEACHERS. ARE ARE-
DESERVING OF RESPECT AND DUE
PROCESS SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. DOT THANK
YOU MISTER MINIT MEDINA THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL BRIAN
O'DONNELL HI KILEY KILEY NO
BENNETT'S BY BENNETT HI SALLY.
DALLI NO LEAKS MCCARTY MCCARTY
HI QUICK SILVA. RICK SILVA I IT
HAS FOUR VOTES BILLS FOR WROTE
IT IS OUT THANK YOU MISTER
MEDINA THANK YOU TO FUTURE WITH
THAT WILL MOVE TO MR SAY
ARTICLE WAS BEEN SITTING OUT
THERE PATIENTLY. IS THIS THE
PRESENTATION OF YOUR FIRST
BILL. NO IT IS NOT. DAN I
THOUGHT WE'RE GONNA LIVE ONE
HERE. YOU CAN FOREGO THAT
MARTIN OKAY I CAN BUT- WELL
WELCOME THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS AND I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR TAKING THE TIME
TO HEAR MY BILL TODAY AB THREE
TWELVE WILL ALLOW. DESIGN WILL
ALLOW. A PARTICULAR TEACHER
CREDENTIALING CANDIDATES
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES TO USE
QUALIFYING COURSEWORK IN ORDER
TO SATISFY THE STATE MANDATED.
BASIC SKILLS REQUIREMENT OR THE
BSR. RIGHT NOW PRUDENTIAL
CANDIDATES CAN CHOOSE FROM A
LIST OF TESTS TO SATISFY THE
VSR INCLUDING THE C. BEST THE
SAT AND ACT EXAMS THE AP EXAMS
AND THE C. S. P. T. ALL OF
THESE TESTS WERE CANCELED DUE
TO COVED AND NOW ARE ONLY
OPERATING AT ABOUT 50%
CAPACITY. WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE
OF AN UNPRECEDENTED TEACHER
SHORTAGE IN CALIFORNIA THAT IS
ONLY BEING MADE WORSE BY THE
CANCELLATION OF TESTS IN THE
COVERT OUTBREAK WE NEED TO
EXPAND AVENUES OF ENTRY INTO.
BEING ARBITRARY BARRIERS TO
PROGRAMS INCREASING FLEXIBILITY
WE CAN BRING IN MORE QUALIFIED
CANDIDATES TO EDUCATE OUR
CHILDREN THE SHORTAGES ARE
ESPECIALLY CONCERNING AS WE
RETURN TO IN PERSON INSTRUCTION
AND REQUIRE EVEN MORE TEACHERS
ACCOMMODATE NOT ONLY OUR
PHYSICAL DISTINCT. DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS BUT ALSO THE-
LEARNING LOSS ISSUE THAT WE
HAVE HERE IN THE STATE. UNLESS
ALTERNATIVE PATHWAYS FOR
CANDIDATES TO DEMONSTRATE BASIC
SKILLS AND COMPETENCY ARE
PROVIDED. THE SUSPENSION OF SEA
BASS TO TESTING WILL MASSIVELY
COMPOUND THE EXISTING TEACHER
SHORTAGE AB THREE TWELVE OFFERS
OUR CREDENTIAL CANDIDATES A
FLEXIBILITY TO FULFILL THE BSR
AND GET INTO THE CLASSROOM
WITHOUT COMPROMISING THE
QUALITY OF TEACHERS OUR SCHOOL
SO DESPERATELY NEED. TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT WE HAVE SASHA
HOROWITZ WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON
TEACHER CREDENTIALING. FOUR
MISTER SCHWARTZ. MAKING VIDEO.
IN THE FINANCE OKAY. SO HE'S
COMING ON OUR BEHALF. OKAY
START PROPERTY. YEAH YOU HEAR
ME. AFTER THE TONE OKAY. I'M
SORRY THE INTRODUCED WE'RE NOT
GOING TO HEAR FROM SOME HER- ON
TEACHER CREDENTIALING. MY ON
ISSUE ARE WE ARE WAITING PLEASE
START. I THANK YOU SOME MEMBERS
THEY ARE DOING JERRY DONNELLAN
MEMBERS- SUCH OVER WHAT'S ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMISSION ON
TEACHER CREDENTIALING. YOU KNOW
THE COMMISSION IS THE STATE
AGENCY RESPONSIBLE FOR
LICENSING ALL PUBLIC SCHOOL
TEACHERS. AND ACCREDITED
PROGRAMS TO TRAIN THEM. THE
COMMISSION SUPPORTS THIS BILL
BECAUSE WILL CREATE NEW
FLEXIBILITY TO ALLOW QUALIFIED
INDIVIDUALS TO ENTER THE
CLASSROOM AND HELP REDUCE THE
TEACHER SHORTAGE. AB THREE
TWELVE ADS ONE NEW OPTION FIRST
BY THE TEACHERS TO MEET THE
BASIC STUFF REQUIREMENT. BY
COMPLETING RELEVANT COLLEGE
COURSEWORK AND WILL OF THE SEA
BASS. IT ALSO ALLOWS EASY. TO
MIX AND NOT FROM AMONG ALL THE
OPTION PERMITTED UNDER CURRENT
LAW INCLUDING THE C. PASSED
SOME TESTS. THESE ARE PASSING
THE SEASON WILL SUBJECTS PLUS
READING SKILLS EXAMINATION.
PASSING CSU EARLIEST PROGRAM
FOR THE CSU. PLACEMENT
EXAMINATIONS. ACHIEVING
EQUALITY SCORE OF ACT OR-
ACHIEVING RECALL SCORE IN THE
COLLEGE BOARD BATES.
EXAMINATION WORK AFTER THE
BASIC OF THE FOR STATE. YEAH WE
ALL. 9% IN TWO THOUSAND
SATISFIED TO REQUIREMENT WITH
THE BEST DESPITE THE BILLION
AVAILABILITY TEST HELD. DAVID
TWENTY TO AND THAT. SEVEN POINT
8% OF EXAMINING IT'S TOUGH TO
SEE ON THE FIRST ATTEMPT.
EIGHTY THREE POINT EIGHT
PERCENT. HALF OF. WHAT THE TAX.
CAN MUST PAY ONE HUNDRED TWO
DOLLARS TEST FEE OR FORTY ONE
DOLLARS THE PAPER TEST THE NEW
YORK TO PAY WEIGHT BRITISH. OR
HEARD BRITISH FEE. MANY CAN'T
GET FROM READ SECOND OF DATA
NOT POSSIBLE FULL TIME MUST
IT'S BEEN A- FEE FREE. TO THE
WORK CLOSELY ASSEMBLY SARAH
STAFF FIND BILL AND PROVIDE
CLEAR DIRECTION AND CONCERT
PROCESS FOR TEACHERS. PROGRAMS
TO VERIFY BASICS THROUGH. FINAL
TO THE COPA NINETY MANY KIND OF
HAVE BEEN TO TAKE A SEAT BACK
TO THE TOW CENTER OR- JACKSON
CENTER. THE GOVERNOR
LEGISLATURE CRITICS. ALLOWING
TO FIRST THE BASICS APART WILL
BE A OF PROPER. OF THIS IS
HAPPENING PEOPLE THE TEACHER
PREPARATION PIPELINE IS A ARE
STILL TO COMPLETE BASIC SKILLS
BEFORE EARNING THEIR
CREDENTIALS. THANK YOU AND.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU HELLO
WILL NOT HEAR FROM MICHAEL. I
BELIEVE IN OPPOSITION. HELLO
CAN YOU HEAR ME THIS WEEKEND
PLEASE PROCEED HELLO. OKAY GOOD
THANKS HI MY NAME IS MICHAEL
ROSKAM WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SUBSTITUTE
TEACHERS AND WERE OPPOSED TO
THIS- WE WILL BASICALLY- WE
BELIEVE THAT IT'LL PUT- LOCRI
TEACHERS INTO THE CLASSROOM
WITH A FOCUS ON SUBSTITUTE
TEACHERS WHO HAVE NOT BEEN
TRAINED. WHO HAVE NOT BEEN
TREATED AS EMPLOYEES IN WHO
HAVE NOT BEEN TREATED FAIRLY IF
YOU WANT TO GET MORE SUBSTITUTE
TEACHERS IN THE IN THE
CLASSROOM THERE ARE WAYS TO GO
ABOUT DOING IT I MEAN I
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS- THIS
BILL HAS SEVERAL COMPONENTS.
WERE OBVIOUSLY INTERESTED. IN
SUBSTITUTE TEACHERS ONE OF THE
WAYS THAT WE CAN DO IT IS WE
CAN TAKE CARE OF- PEOPLE
USUALLY WE SUBMITTED A LETTER-
ALONG WITH- SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS- THEY WERE NOT
REFLECTED IN THE ANALYSIS WE
WOULD LIKE TO TALK TO COMMITTEE
AT SOME PARTICULAR POINT ABOUT
HOW TO GO ABOUT EXPANDING THE
CONCEPT TO GET SUBSTITUTE
TEACHERS IN THE CLASSROOM. FOR
EXAMPLE ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
SHOULD BE DONE IS THE COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION SHOULD BE
THE ONES WHO ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR HIRING SUBSTITUTES FOR
EIGHT COUNTY. INSTEAD OF
SUBSTITUTE TEACHERS HAVING TO
GO IN AND REGISTER ANY
PARTICULAR DISTRICT PAY FOR-
BISA EXCUSE ME PAY FOR-
FINGERPRINTS AND THAT KIND OF
STUFF IF WE GET IT IN ONE
PARTICULAR SPOT COUNTY OF
OFFICE OF EDUCATION WE WOULD
HAVE THE ABILITY TO WORK IN ALL
THE DISTRICTS WITHIN THE
COUNTY. THE PROBLEM IS RIGHT
NOW YOU HAVE PRIVATE BUSINESSES
TO DO THAT BUT THEY TAKE 20% OF
EVERYTHING AS A SUBSTITUTE
TEACHER ARE. YOU REAL PROBLEM
BECOMES. IF WE START PUTTING
PEOPLE IN THE CLASSROOM WHO ARE
LET'S SAY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY SIX. THEY HAVE NO
EXPERIENCE THE KIDS IN A HIGH
SCHOOL ARE GOING TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THESE PEOPLE
THEY'RE GONNA THAT THE CLASSES
ARE NOT GOING TO BE- R. AS
APPROPRIATE AS THEY SHOULD BE
AND THE NUMBER ONE THING THAT
HAPPENS IS. AND THAT IS THEY
GET FIRED. THE BOTTOM IS A
RIGHT FOR SUCH TEACH IN. IF YOU
MORE TO IN THE CLASSROOM HOW TO
FIX THE SYSTEM THAT SUBSIDY
TEACHERS DEAL WITH. WE ASK YOU
TO NO THIS. IT'S NOT GOOD FOR
SUBSTITUTE. THANK YOU GREAT
THANK YOU. WE'VE FROM SOME
OPPOSITE WENT OVER BACK TO THE-
I'M GONNA SUPPORT THIS BILL
TODAY I STRUGGLE WITH IT A BIT
JUST AS ONE WHO IS A TEACHER.
AND STILL SUBS ABOUT THE FALL
ARE. YOU KNOW WHAT I JUST HEARD
A WITNESS MENTIONED PRIVATE
COMPANIES HIRING SUBSTITUTES
WILL. BE A VIOLATION AB FIVE
BUT EITHER WAY I DON'T THINK
PRIVATE COMPANIES SHOULD BE.
HIRING SUBSTITUTES AND PUTTING
A PUBLIC SCHOOL CLASSROOM THAT
SEEMS RATHER COMPLICATED TO ME.
AND MAYBE NOT SAFE BUT I
APPRECIATE. THE OPPOSITION'S
COMMENTS ABOUT SOLIDIFYING- THE
PREPARATION OF A SUBSTITUTE
TEACHER I DON'T KNOW THAT
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILLS TOTALLY
ABOUT ALTHOUGH THERE IS SOME
OVERLAP MAYBE. BUT I THINK THAT
IS AN ISSUE WE COULD ALWAYS
CONTEMPLATE GOING FORWARD BUT
TODAYAGAIN I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT THE BILL. ARE THERE ANY
OTHER COMMENTS RATHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MISS CORK SILVA- YEAH I
AND I AND- DID NOT READ IT IN
DETAIL JUST THE SYNOPSIS BUT IS
THERE A TIMELINE ON THIS AS- I
KNOW THAT IT'S IT REFERENCING.
THE PANDEMIC IN THE URGENCY TO
GET TEACHERS. CREDENTIAL
INNOCENCE AND SO FORTH BUT IS
THERE A TIMELINE ON IT THERE'S
NO SUNSET CLAUSE THAT. THAT'S A
FANTASTIC. THIS THE THIS IS TO
TRY TO GET TO BACK INTO THE
SAID AND I WANTED TO. OUT ALL
TO THE SPEAKERS THANK THIS DOES
NOT SIR. THE HIRING PROCESS OF
A TEACHER- SO THE QUALITY OF
TEACHERS IS UP TO THE BOARD TO
HIRE THEM. EDITED EDUCATION
SYSTEM THE HIGHER.AND THEN I
THINK A QUESTION FOR THE CHAIR
IS. I KNOW THE C. BEST HAS
ALWAYS BEEN REQUIRED TO HIRE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS BUT THEN
DISTRICTS INDIVIDUALLY
SOMETIMES ADD THEIR OWN
PROCESSES ON TOP OF THAT IT IS
THAT STILL THE CASE AS FAR AS
JUST HAVING THEIR OWN. IF YOU
WANT TO SAY ALMOST LIKE A
VERSION OF C. BEST SO ARE YOU
TALK ABOUT THE HIRING PROCESS
OR THE CEDARS I'M TALKING ABOUT
THAT. IN ORDER TO BE HIRED IN
CALIFORNIA YOU HAVE TO PASS A
SEA BASS THAT'S KIND OF BEEN
THE COULDN'T. STAND THE OTHER
HAS HERE'S A PRETTY CLEAN BILL
OF SPEAKS TO THE C. BEST NOT
NECESSARILY THE HIRING PROCESS
I WOULD ARGUE THE HIRING
PROCESS IS SOMETHING WE CAN
CONTEMPLATE BUT I DON'T THINK
HE'S REALLY. THE SMELL MIGHT
LIKE NOT TRYING TO IMPACT IN
ANY MAN OF THE HIRING PROCESS
RIGHT NAY BUT IT'S JUST I KNOW
SOME OF THE CONCERNS MIGHT BE.
THAT IF YOU DON'T HAVE TO PASS
THE C. BEST AND THAT'S BEEN THE
STANDARD ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND OTHER DISTRICTS
YOU KNOW INDIVIDUALLY CAN- PUT
WHATEVER TYPE OF ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENTS THEY HAVE ON
HIRING. THAT YOU COULD HAVE
SOME DISTRICTS WHICH MUCH MORE
EXTENSIVE TYPES OF HIRING
PROCESSES. AND THEN SOME THAT
WILL. WITH THIS BILL TAKE.
THESE ITEMS THAT YOU'RE
SUGGESTING COULD. BE IN LIEU OF
THE C. BEST PRICE I DON'T THINK
THAT ALREADY EXISTS. OKAY THE I
THINK THE IDEA TO DO THAT.
THANK YOU- BOB. TINA FURTHER
COMMITMENT. SORT OF A NATURAL
COMMON BUT THE ISSUE ABOUT
HAVING SUBSTITUTE TEACHERS BE
ABLE TO- DO THE FINGERPRINTING
IN THE WHOLE COUNTY SEEMS LIKE
A RIGHT TOPIC FOR FUTURE
CONSIDERATIONS BUT I SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU. SOUNDS
GOOD- SINGLE FURTHER FROM
COMMENT FROM MANY WHAT WE'LL DO
IS WE'LL GO TO THE PHONES- TEN
MINUTES ON THE PHONES. THANK
YOU TO STATE YOUR POSITION YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN THE ZERO
WE'LL GO FIRST TO LINE EIGHTY
FOUR. EIGHT FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING TURN MEMBERS
DEREK BLACK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT EDUCATIONAL
SERVICES ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB THREE EIGHTY
EIGHT. OPEN SORRY THREE TWENTY.
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE THIRTY
FOUR ONE THREE FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN WELL. YES GOOD MORNING
MISTER TURNER NUMBERS GRIFFITHS
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BOARDS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT WE HAVE
WANT LINE ONE THIRTY THREE ONE
THREE THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MAKE SURE MEMBERS JOHN LINGER
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHARTER SCHOOLS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT. CAROLINE ONE THIRTY
EIGHT ONE THREE EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LINE ONE THIRTY EIGHT
ARE YOU ON MUTE. GOOD MORNING
MARKET ABOUT THE- REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER- CAL
COMING TOGETHER IN THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
BILINGUAL AND THEN WE SUPPORT
THANK. I HAVE TO DO ONE QUICK
TESTIMONY ON THE BILL IN A
SECOND. ONE TWENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN THERE WE GO. THANK
YOU RICHARD MEMBERS TOOK TO
BROWN WITH THIS YEAR HE ALSO
SUPPORTED THIS BILL. NEXT
DEADLINE ONE THIRTY SIX ONE
THREE SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
DILUTES HERE FROM ADVICE OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED FOR THE REASON
THAT ON PAGE EIGHT OKAY NOW
THAT. WELL GOOD LINE EIGHTY SIX
EIGHT SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ISABEL GARCIA
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF THE BALLOT. NEXT WE HAVE ONE
FIFTY FIVE FIVE FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR CHAU
PROGRAM WITH PUBLIC ADVOCATE
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE
TWELVE THANK YOU. NOW LINE ONE
THIRTY FIVE ONE THREE FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
ALEX THE ASSOCIATION
INDEPENDENT CALIFORNIA COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES AND OR FORTY
THREE SCHOOLS AND PROGRAMS OF
EDUCATION AND SUPPORT. NEXT IN
LINE EIGHTY TWO ONE EIGHT TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FOUR FIVE
SENATORS STATION A CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS AND
STRONG SUPPORT. MODOC KLEIN
EIGHTY SEVEN EIGHT SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. APOLOGIZE THE SEVEN
ARE YOU WANT ME. WILL MOVE ON
THE LINE ONE OF SIX ONE HUNDRED
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
MORNING CRISTINA MARCELLUS ON
BEHALF OF THE SMALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK MISTER NO FOR
THE LINES INTO AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU- DO WE HAVE A MOTION
ON THIS YET. I BELIEVE NOT WE
ARE MOTION. SECOND AND MOVED
AND SECONDED- THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS YOU MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU AYE ASPREY AYE
VOTE. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL RIGHT
FOR DONALD HI KILEY. KILEY NOT
VOTING BENNETT HI SENATE I
DALLY DALLY I LIED MCCARTY
MCCARTY I QUICK SILVA.
QUICKSILVER I THE BILL HAS FIVE
VOTES BILLS BY VOTERS OUT THANK
COULD WORK. WILL THAT WILL MOVE
TO. E. EIGHT TWENTY FOUR MISTER
BENNETT THAT'S FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE. FILE ITEM NUMBER. ONE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE- IF
YOU SHARE- BILL CLINTON. TWO
MORE THE I'M SORRY THIS ONE AND
I BELIEVE ONE OTHER. SO THERE'S
TWO TOTAL INCLUDING THIS ONE.
YEP AND CONVENTION WE HAVE BEEN
CENTER. WHENEVER WE DO THE
CONSENT NOW. DO WE ARE MOTION
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IT'S BEEN
MOVED WE ARE SECOND IT'S BEEN
SECONDED PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTIONS ARE AB ONE TWENTY
SIX WITH AMENDMENTS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AB TWO
EIGHTY FIVE TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. AB THREE ZERO SIX
WITH AMENDMENTS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AB
THREE TWENTY TO THE HIGHER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE. EIGHTY
FOUR THIRTY SEVEN TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AB
FIVE SIXTEEN TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. AB
EIGHT FIFTY SIX WITH AMENDMENTS
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
AND AB TEN THIRTY NINE TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
O'DONNELL HI DONALD HI KILEY.
KILEY AYE BENNETT AYE BENNETT
AYE DALLI. DALLI I LEAD.
MCCARTY THANK MCCARTY I QUICK
SILVA. QUICKSILVER HI THAT HAS
SIX VOTES THE SIXERS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS THAT WE'RE
GOING NOW BACK TO AB EIGHT
TWENTY FOUR MISTER BENNETT FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE PLEASE PROCEED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR OF FIRST I'D LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR COOPERATION AND WE WILL
ACCEPT ALL OF THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS- IN POWERING-
STUDENTS THAT HAS. SIGNIFICANT
EDUCATIONAL BENEFITS IN THE
SYSTEM AND THAT'S WHY THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA HAS ALREADY
ALLOWED STUDENTS TO PETITION TO
BE NON BINDING OF VOTING
MEMBERS OF THEIR PUBLIC SCHOOL
DISTRICT BOARDS- THIS BILL- AB
EIGHT TWENTY FOUR- WILL MODIFY
THAT AND THIS BILL WAS CREATED
IN COLLABORATION WITH SO TO
STUDENT LED ORGANIZATIONS A
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS
ASSOCIATION AND- JET UP- AND WE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK WITH THOSE TWO
ORGANIZATIONS. THIS BILL WILL
ALLOW STUDENTS ALSO TO PETITION
TO HAVE A SEAT ON THE COUNTY
BOARD OF EDUCATION AND THE
CHARTER SCHOOL GOVERNING
BOARDS- WITH THE AGAIN A
PREFERENTIAL BUT NON BINDING OF
VOTING RIGHTS TO ADVOCATE ON
BEHALF OF THE STUDENTS SAID TO
MAKE SURE THAT STUDENT VOICE AT
LEAST HAS AN OPPORTUNITY TO BE
PRESENTED AT SCHOOL BOARD-MEETING SO- WITH THAT I WOULD
ENCOURAGE AN AYE VOTE ON THIS
MEASURE. GREAT THANK YOU MISTER
BENNETT- YOU'RE IN SUPPORT IT
APPEARS YOU HAVE ZACHARY.
PETERSON ON THE PHONE. GOOD
MORNING AUDIBLE MEMBERS OF THE
OFFENSE EDUCATION COMMITTEE
ZACHARY COULD NOT BE HERE TODAY
AND MICHELLE ALICE I AM BE
POLICY DIRECTOR FOR BOTH THE
CALIFORNIA BOARD MEMBERS OF
THESE. ADS ARE NOT FROM THE
FOURTEENTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
AND I'M A STUDENT BOARD MEMBER
FOR THE MOUNT DIABLO UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT. BOTH OF OUR
ORGANIZATIONS ARE STUDENT LED
CO SPONSORS OF THE BELGIAN
COLLECTIVELY REPRESENT TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS FROM
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WE WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS THE
URGENT NECESSITY FOR THE BILL
ESPECIALLY NOW MORE THAN A- NON
STUDENT GOVERNING BOARD MEMBERS
ARE MAKING DECISIONS ABOUT OUR
HELP. OUR LEARNING AND OUR
FUTURE WE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
BOARD MEMBER ASSOCIATION BROKE
THE SPELL WITH THE INTENTION OF
BRIDGING A GAP IN EDUCATION
GOVERNANCE. THIRTY FOUR MEMBERS
THE ALMOST EVERY DECISION
MAKING LEVEL AND EDUCATION IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA YEAH
WELL BUT CALIFORNIA WILL
DISTRICT. AND THEN YOU HAVE THE
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION.
THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT OUR
PRESENTATION AT THE
INTERMEDIATE LEVEL ACCOUNTING
BOARD OF EDUCATION AND FELT THE
SUBJECT BOB. WHAT ABOUT THE
ABILITY TO CONTRIBUTE TO THE
FASHION BASED ON INFORMED
FIRSTHAND. EXPERIENCES BOARD
MEMBERS ARE INJURED TO THE FOR.
OF A LOCAL. AGENCY WE ARE CLOSE
THE STOCK WITH EXISTING LOGIC.
THAT IS ALREADY. ON BEFORE THE
LEVEL. AT THE CHARTER SCHOOL
LEVEL IN THE NOT CONFLICT I'M
WITH HIM FOR MEMBER FOR THE
KNOCKED OUT THE UNIFIED FOR
THIS MARIPOSA ONE CHART SCHOOL.
BUT THERE ARE ROUGHLY YOU. BY
MEANS OF BEING A CHARTER DAY
ARTICLE WHO FOR THE COMPARE
THAT CHART GOVERNMENT MAKE
DECISIONS AND THAT INTERESTS OF
THOSE THIRD. AND ONLY WHAT YOU
NEED AND BY PRIME STATE BEAR
WORKING TO THE WE WERE. BY
CHARGING SCHOOL STUDENTS OUR
END OF WILL SIX THAT WE HAVE
CALPERS SUPPORT OF AND BUT. I
THINK REPRESENT BAD. AND THEY
DID NOT A METHOD REPRESENTS
HIMSELF. I NEEDED UP WHATEVER
POSITION FOR THEIR OWN
GOVERNMENT. THE CHARTERED HAD
DIFFERENT GOVERNMENTS ASSEMBLY
HEARING SHE- TO HAVE A- OF.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY BAND THANK
YOU. FELL I WAS. URGE AND I
VOTE FROM EACH OF THE- THANK
YOU VERY. THANK YOU OUR NEXT
ARE WE- IN SERVE. IS- MACHEL A
LOS. RIGHT THAT'S IT YEAH I
APOLOGIZE IS IT THAT IS IT FOR
THE WITNESS WERE I THERE ARE NO
WAY AND ALL TO APPEARS SO IT'S
BRING A BACK- TO THE COMMITTEE
AND IT COMES FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. SAY A COMMENCEMENT OF
COMMITTEE MAY SO WE HAVE A
MOTION. THANK IT REMOVED AND
SEVEN. OP OF WHAT IT WAS GO TO
THE PHONES FOR- UP TO TEN
MINUTES. YOU TO STATE YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS BILL ME PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO USING YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD AGAIN THAT'S A
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. WELL THE
FIRST THE LINE FIFTY THREE FIVE
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IT
WON'T. NUMBER. FOUR EIGHT EIGHT
THREE FOUR THANK YOU. WE'LL GO
NEXT TO LINE ONE THIRTY TWO ONE
THREE TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ALICE COOPER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION AND WE DON'T YET
HAVE A POSITION- BUT LOOK
FORWARD TO CONSIDERING ONE ONE
THREE THREE BA COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS ARE PRINTED BONTA
THANK THE AUTHOR AND THE
COMMITTEE. FOR HELPING US WORK
OUT HARDER RELATED PROVISIONS
THERE'S A FEW ITEMS WE STILL
THINK THERE MIGHT BE A LITTLE
WORK TO DO BUT WE'RE MAKING
GOOD PROGRESS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. WILL THE LINES. TWO SEVEN
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
JASON CHEN WITH WITH CAST- ALSO
THE THIRD SHOULD YOU COUNSELED
IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT. NEXT WE
HAVE LINE THIRTY EIGHT THREE
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. STE
WARNING MISTER CHAIRMAN ENEMY
CUNNING SHOW FOR REPRESENTING
CANNOT LOOK FUNDING
ORGANIZATION AND A FORMER
STUDENT BOARD MEMBER OF THE
DOWNEY UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
EIGHTY FOUR. ANY FURTHER
COMMENT ON THE PHONE. YES THANK
YOU WILL GO NEXT TO LINE NINETY
NINE ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ALL THE MEDIA OF A PUBLIC HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS AND FREMONT IN
THE BAY AREA AND I'M A MEMBER
GEN UP AND I'D LIKE TO STRONGLY
VOICED MY SUPPORT AB EXACTLY.
NEXT HOGAN ONLINE NINETY FOUR
NINE FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINETY FOUR DO YOU HAVE A
POSITION ON THIS BILL. THIS
WILL MOVE THE LINE FIFTY SIX
FIVE SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS LOCAL SO CLERK
COME FROM THE FIFTEENTH
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR ALBANY UNIFIED AND
THE DIRECTOR OF RESOURCES FOR
THE CALIFORNIA SINGAPORE
MEMBERS ASSOCIATION AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME AND ARE
YOU I WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE- COMMITTEE- WE DO HAVE A
MOTION. AND A SECOND- THE
MOTION IS TO PASS OF AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS YOU MAY CLOSE. I
ENCOURAGE AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
O'DONNELL I WOULD ON ALL AYE
KILEY. KILEY AYE BENNETT AYE
BENNETT AYE DALY. PLEASE FIVE
MCCARTY MCCARTY THANK PLEASE
AYE MCCARTY AYE QUICK SILVA
QUICK SILVA BY. THE BILL HAS
SEVEN VOTES. THANK YOU THE
BILLS OUT. SHE'S GIVEN A
MUNICIPAL. THE OTHER A LITTLE.
WHAT THE. NEXT WE HAVE ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE FORTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER O'DONNELL
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AT ALL YOU MAY
PROCEED. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS AB FIVE FOUR FOUR
REQUIRES SUPERINTENDENTS OF
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION AND
ADMINISTRATORS OF CHARTER
SCHOOLS TO REPORT INFORMATION
ABOUT EACH SCHOOL FACILITIES
OWNED OR LEASED. BY THE LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCY TO THE CD. IN
ORDER FOR BASIC FACILITY
INFORMATION SO THAT BASIC
FACILITY I'M INFORMATION MAY BE
REPORTED TO OTHERS LOCAL STATE
AND FEDERAL AGENCIES TO ASSIST
WITH EMERGENCY RESPONSE. WHEN
AN EMERGENCY SUCH AS FLOOD
CONTAGIOUS DISEASE WILDFIRE OR
OTHER DISASTER OCCURS. LOCAL
STATE AND FEDERAL AGENCIES NEED
BASIC INFORMATION REGARDING
PUBLIC SCHOOL FACILITIES. THE
PRIMARY NEED FOR THIS
INFORMATION IS TO ENSURE
STUDENT SAFETY. LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT RATHER AGENCIES
LOOK TO SCHOOL LEADERS AND
ADMINISTRATORS TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION ABOUT STUDENTS AND
SCHOOL PERSONNEL LOCATION
DURING AN EVACUATION. IN
ADDITION. GOVERNMENT AGENCIES
MAY NEED TEMPORARY LOCATIONS TO
SET UP A HOUSING FOR EMERGENCY
PERSONNEL SHELTERS FOR EVACUEES
OR FACILITIES TO ESTABLISH
TEMPORARY CLINICS. DESPITE THE
NEED FOR BASIC INFORMATION
ABOUT THE LOCATION OF
FACILITIES A SCHOOL BUILDINGS
DURING EMERGENCY CALIFORNIA
LACKS AN INVENTORY OF SCHOOL
FACILITY LOCATIONS AND FACILITY
INFORMATION. DURING THE
DEVASTATING WILDFIRES OF THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS THERE WAS AT
TIMES CONFUSION AT THE LOCAL
AND STATE LEVEL AMONG EMERGENCY
RESPONSE PERSONNEL RELATED TO
THE LOCATION OF SCHOOL
BUILDINGS DUE TO THIS LACK OF
EXISTING INFORMATION AMADOR.
ALTHOUGH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
CURRENTLY COLLECTS BOTH THE
PHYSICAL AND MAILING ADDRESS OF
SCHOOL SIDES. THE STATE
CURRENTLY HAS NO MECHANISM OR
REQUIREMENT FOR COLLECTING
INFORMATION RELATED TO A SINGLE
SCHOOL SITE WITH MULTIPLE
BUILDINGS OR LOCATIONS. AB FIVE
FOUR FOUR REQUIRES A AN ALLEY A
TO REPORT THIS INFORMATION ONCE
AND PROVIDE UPDATES ONLY WHEN
THERE HAS BEEN A CHANGE. AB
FIVE FOUR FIVE FOUR FOUR WILL
CREATE A STATEWIDE WILL CREATE
A STATE WIDE CRITICAL INVENTORY
OF SCHOOL FACILITIES. WHEN THIS
INFORMATION IS READILY
AVAILABLE SCHOOL AND EMERGENCY
PERSONNEL CAN BETTER COORDINATE
RESPONSE ACTIVITIES TO ENSURE
STUDENT AND SCHOOL PERSONAL
PERSONAL SAFETY AS WELL AS A
SAFETY OF THE COMMUNITY AT
LARGE. RG I SHOULD ALSO ADD
THAT EXCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS WILL TO FURTHER
CLARIFY THE SPECIFIC
INFORMATION ELLIE IS MUST
REPORT. TO CD INCLUDING A
REQUIRED FOR ALL THESE PROVIDE
INFORMATION ON THE STATUS OF
SCHOOL FACILITIES DURING AN
EMERGENCY CAUSED BY A NATURAL
DISASTER. WITHOUT BACKING MR.
APPEARS WE HAVE NO DOESN'T NEED
WITNESSES- IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION SO WE'LL OVE AHEAD
WITH COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS YES ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CORK SILVA- I WOULD ASK
THEM AUTHOR TO BE A CO AUTHOR
ON THE US AYE IT'S AN VERY
IMPORTANT BILL AND MAY NOT MAKE
HEADLINES RIGHT NOW BUT IT'S-
IN EVERYTHING THAT WE HAVE SEEN
HAPPENING NOT ONLY WITH OUR
ENVIRONMENT BUT CERTAINLY-
OTHER- SCENARIOS THAT WE'VE
SEEN ON CAMPUSES US SCHOOL
SHOOTINGS AND SO FORTH WE NEED
TO HAVE.THE MOST UP TO DATE
INFORMATION SO THAT IT CAN BE
EASILY ACCESSED BY THE PEOPLE
THAT NEED THAT AND ONLY THOSE
PEOPLE THAT NEED IT CORRECT.
THAT IS BUILT INTO THE BILLS
WILL. REMOVE THE BILL THANK.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VALLEY. SO THAT
THE DATA COLLECTED WILL BE
COLLECTED- HOUSE WITH THE CD SO
LAW ENFORCEMENT WILL THEY
REQUEST THAT ARE HOW THEY SHARE
IT I'M SORRY SO IF YOU'RE
COUNTY LAW ENFORCEMENT I'M JUST
THINKING ABOUT OUR SMALL SCHOOL
SO WELL THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT HAVE TO REQUEST THE
DATA ONCE IT'S COLLECTED OR HOW
WILL THAT BE SHARED OUT TO
COUNTY IS LAW ENFORCEMENT. IN A
CALLOW YES MAIM NEED THE
BUILDINGS HOW WILL THE DATA BE
SHARED. BOB THERE WILL BE A
PROCESS SET UP WHEREBY CD WOULD
SHARE THAT WITH THEM- ON AN
IMMEDIATE BASIS OKAY. THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM.
WHO WAS TO TESTIFY. WITH OVER
THE PHONE LINES FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. THANK YOU TO STATE
YOUR POSITION ON THIS BILLING
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON
YOUR PHONE AGAIN THAT'S ONE AND
THEN THEY'RE ALL. ON THE LINE
NINETY FOUR. MOBILINE TWENTY
THREE TO THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MISTER VICE CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TONY TO KERO
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU. OUR NEXT
COMMENT IS FROM NINE THIRTY
EIGHT THREE EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WARNING THAT THE GERMAN.
SHEPHERD REPRESENTING DONE
NOTHING IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
AT THIS TIME THERE ARE NO
FURTHER LINES IN Q. MISTER
DONALD JUDD CLOSE. AS RIVAL THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS ABOUT
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
YES THEY DO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL FIVE
BUT ALL I KILEY. KILEY I'D
BENNETT AYE BENNETT AYE DALY.
LEE HI MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY
MCCARTY I. KIRK SILVA CORK
SILVA HI MY APOLOGIES THE BILL
HAS SEVEN VOTES. WE'LL DO OUT
ON. AND THERE'S NOTHING ON CALL
IF YOU HAVE YOUR ADAMS. THE
IT'S BEEN A PRIVILEGE. FOR LIKE
THREE DOLLARS. OKAY WHICH IS
REALLY JUST A- MEMBERS OF YOU
WISH TO ADD ON ANY BILL AT THIS
TIME PLEASE STAY SEATED WITH
YOUR MICROPHONES ON WHETHER
COMMITTEE SECRETARY CALLED THE
ROLL ON EACH ITEM AND WHY THIS
IS SUCH. AN IMPORTANT THING
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE IN THE PAST
WE HAD MEMBERS YELL OUT THINGS
AND I WALK OUT OF THE ROOM AND
WE JUST NEED TO DO IS DO THIS
RIGHT GET IT DONE QUICKLY I'M
ONLY THIS ONCE- BUT IF YOU JUST
STAY HERE WE CAN GO THROUGH A
PRETTY RAPIDLY WE WILL DO SO
NOW. MISTER CHARITY WANT TO
GOBBLE DOWN- IT'S JUST. THIS
COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED- THE
FIRST VOTE WILL BE ON THE
ADOPTION OF THE COMMITTEE RULES.
MCCARTY RIGHT MCCARTY HI. THE
FIRST BILL IS AB TWENTY SEVEN.
THE CHAIR VOTED BY BENNETT HI
BENNETT I BELIEVE. HI LEE I.
THE NEXT BILL IS AB ONE OH
FOUR. THE CHAIR VOTED I'D
BENNETT. BENNETT I LEAVE. HI
LEE I. THE NEXT BILL IS AB
THREE TWELVE. THE CHAIR VOTED I
PLEASE. HI LEE HI. AB THREE SIX
SEVEN THE CHAIR VOTED I'D LEAVE
HI LEE I MCCARTY MCCARTY HI. AB
THREE EIGHT EIGHT THE CHAIR
VOTED I'D LEAVE NEVADA LEAD NOT
VOTING. AB FIVE FIVE TO THE
CHAIR VOTED AYE BENNETT'S LINE
PLANET AYE LEAVE BY LEE I. AB
FIVE SIX THREE. THE CHAIR VOTED
I LEAVE. HI LEE I MCCARTY
MCCARTY HI. AB EIGHT ONE FIVE
THE CHAIR VOTED BY BENNETT
BENNETT I BELIEVE. HI LEE I.
AND FINALLY THE CONSENT
CALENDAR- LEAD HI LEAI. THAT IS
IT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
CONGRATULATIONS TO OUR OUR NEW
MEMBERS WHO SURVIVED THE FIRST
HEARING. THIS IS MUCH SHORTER
THAN SOME OF OUR WHAT MAYBE.
NINE OR TEN OUR HEARINGS WE'VE
HAD IN THE PAST. THE ADVANTAGE
THE ADVANTAGE OF COVERT.